au yoga
bon je sais que tu as fait le le pré
stream juste avant quoi ouais alors
attends je vais fermer quelques petits
trucs ce que la connexion c'est vraiment
juste juste tonton c'était beaucoup
mieux sur je ne sais pas si on va tenir
avec la tête des joueurs on va voir on
va voir non ça a l'air de stabiliser la
connexion fab 1 on a stabilisé la
connexion n'est bon premier lieu ceux ci
ont su heures ce nom du stream pas du
tout on vote mais j'ai changé le nom du
kremlin
alors ça c'est bon c'est rechange et 11
km en sueur les gars mais c'est génial
le nom du srifa réalisation sueur
comment j'étais heureux enfin tout le
monde est en sueur
en fait le live ne marche pas patience
et dise que ça marche pourquoi tu as ça
et ça marche on fait ça marche chez
certains singes causé d'autres si ça
marche c'est parti bon allez je vais mon
retour sur le discorde pour dire de
venir
ça faisait trois mois j'étais j'ai mieux
lui parler mais je reviens oui discorde
mais en fait
en fait je sais pas c'est pas méga
stable c'est pas méga stable avec le
avec la tête des joueurs une nouvelle
fois faire la guerre fois ça marchait
pas du tout là je sais pas un niveau
stabilité où on en est bonjour sera pas
dit que nous en fait dans le chat si ses
côtes mans ridicule ou pas le stream sur
la tête des mecs tout ça ou pas du tout
l'âme la tête des mecs j'ai pas encore
mis mais on va la voir ce que tu es là
je vais là ajouté mais
du coup en fait je mettrai à 8 heures je
viens tu l'as déjà pas me et des hommes
non mais sinon mais si je feins elle est
ouverte et que hal a jugé que la gca la
m j'ai calé mettre à l'écran en fait
donc du coup les gars si vous êtes là
partagé de partout sur les réseaux
sociaux pompiers du monde qui regarde sa
rue gouraud match local scène i
bon bah gros favoris même l'ordi a
calculé que des algorithmes évalue ses
chances de gags plus de 95% contre
contre socoa mais bon un jax et des baux
échec c'est pas mal ce qui nous fait car
le sel est allé on se parle et on se
marre bien
de toute façon soyez pas sûr donc femmes
on mettra pas on préfère la caméra des
joueurs à nos caméras moi j'ai juste et
c'est la mienne parce qu'elle nie et de
base mais sinon je pense que la caméra
des joueurs beaucoup plus en plus
important mais est ce que toi tu
m'entends bien en fait c'est un peu la
question que j'ai envie de te poser
ouah je t'entends ça va parce que le
fait que les gens entendent bien c'est
sûr est-ce que la rediffusion du mac
sera disponible en boîte akbar à wez
imagine tu trouveras sur youtube sur la
chaîne jeunesse comme quoi la supply
chain
brad à caen sur le bon c'est une chaîne
à me salir le droit d'aller voir n'est
pas le droit d'être partout mais là oui
j'ai le droit
c'est martin a pas le droit et pour le
coup j'ai quatre se renommer la rampe
bord du jet ski dans n'importe quelle
position
à bas les immenses et le truc quoi des
vous jouez vous partie sur internet en
club on retournera à l'analyse
oui je veux le bord du jet ski quoi bon
le même pas comprendre moi-même mon
petit à petit ils vont comprendre quoi a
déjà je pense que plus en plus de gens
comment est-ce que ces deux jeux dans
l'esprit des buts savais pas trop ce qui
nous inquiète c'est post esprit et mon
bain est bon mais voilà on fait évoluer
les moeurs c'est bien on apprend les
audi vrai échec aux gens voilà les
échecs grecque il y avait là hashtag le
football devrait
le hashtag liste d'échecs vrai quoi
switched auto dès que ça marche pas chez
lui mais ça c'est peut-être si c'est
qu'un c'est ça à cause d'un problème de
twitch c'est pas moi mais j'ai
l'impression que mais ils disent que la
qualité est complètement pourri
merci tranquille dit on va se nicher les
huées que cette qualité ouais c'est
vraiment moche moche alors c'est moi je
ne regarde pas tu vas tellement je veux
pas savoir combien peuple non mais
attends je mens des caméras se sont
changés quelle horreur
1 c'est parti la première amende se
lancent souvent des blancs comme ça
d'aller voir à ce que tu as à me défiler
j'ai pas encore écrit en fait le truc
les gens c'est qu'alors silva attends je
vais lui mettre la chance remettre les
caméras en fait mais en fait il ya une
personne qui que c'est pourri c'est que
ça vient de chez elle en fait c'est
juste ça peut pas venir de loin en fait
il n'y a qu'une personne qui dit que
c'est pourri bon je constate jouer au
jeu des pronostics dès le début un je
m'en fous mawâzine tu as tout à fait
raison
ben voyons c'est vrai tu en train de
faire le maximum pour que vous ayez la
tête des joueurs pour que vous ayez tous
les méthodes rugissent de manu arrête tu
regardes tu l'as fait au 6b ci-dessous
g7 g6 dégage pas on attend la suite
quand même on décide qui est un set ça
moi je tente
je prie on veut des six dans les annonay
maintenant
première erreur de magnus dans ce match
alors attends attends tu entends mais je
suis toujours sur mes caméras en fait
excuses - fab
parce qu'en fait j'ai mis en scène on
s'en fiche en scène des gages sur i 4 on
veut saut dans le monde s'aime beaucoup
n'ont en rien à un reto suri 4
[Musique]
nathan enfin que j'essaye de bien car et
tout ça et on va être bon les mecs
voilà je les trouve plus maintenant les
mecs mais c'est pas ça que voilà c'est
ça que je prends pas ce site internet
des caméras à la neutralité dans un
petit peu et puis au pire on sent le
truc c'est que maintenant on peut plus
partir de une fois quand même y les
caméras le truc c'est que si on part on
enlève les caméras de tout le monde quoi
on défend tous les stream en fait blue
stream mais met la planète entière en pl
là ce serait pour la peine vraiment
visserie match et ce point comme en pls
on s'est sauvé des gens peu l'attention
avec ses chevaux non mais si les mecs
disent que l'alcool et que la caméra ou
là si les mecs disent que le scream ça
va c'est que ça va
non non fabre caméra on ne vendra pas
faire on va on m'a pris pour favoriser
préférer les joueurs bon elle sait faire
du coup bon bah faut changer d'opérateur
quoi on numericable le truc c'est que je
suis sûr en jeu mais orange ne veux pas
me donner à fives en fait certainement
bain mais oui enfin personne ne me le
donner sauf que sfr comme ils sont en
pls de niveau 50 à skis non plus de
nouveau là bas n'ont eux ils m'ont dit
oui nous vous la met bas joigny fin
vient je t'attends ah oui oui nous
venons le 30 octobre unis vont venir
enfin moi je ne suis pas chez moi mais
bien quand même enfin je donne les clés
les mecs viennent et la bombe à mon père
qui a ouvert le truc et les manifs on va
lever l'installateur d'affaires il est
en baisse de niveau 50 quoi le mec est
venu il a vu fous je ne peux pas faire
cette installation seule faille les mecs
ne voulait pas beaucoup trop oublié
beaucoup trop compliqué il m'a dit faut
au minimum être de mise
peut-être trois oui il faut une échelle
massacre car defour est faible de tous
les côtés on s'aime plus qu elle couche
avec les blancs on en pls une partie à
l'image du match
non mais ok mais c'est un massacre
faille à la paire de fouilles à le pion
c4 faible jahjaga l'écart est assez on
ne comprend plus mais vous savez pas que
monsieur pas deviner les coudes et blanc
donc c'est vrai mais en fait j'ai un peu
discuté avant le match avec d'autres
joueurs et les ouïes machin est ce que
tu chasses points comme n'a pas un peu
exagéré en donnant plus 9,1 je pense pas
même si la chose sous-estimant fait
mahfoud et gastien je fais fou des
quatre qui dégage
bon bah enfin peut-être
j'ai cinq dames je sais tout pro 3 dames
des quatre français nous
1 0 mais il est où
mais il est ou ouest et non mais on est
pour carlson ce soir julie côté ouest et
ce au début
en fait je suis d'autant plus pas tu
sais pourquoi je suis encore plus monde
pour car le sel non parce que c'est nul
bah oui paris envie de dire enfin moi
j'ai finir c'est pas notre avis fait nul
moi j'ai sonné rêve quoi
c'est ça en fait tu comprends la logique
d'un mois par un but après une partie
contre carl scène j'avais un meilleur
score que sow puis je me suis pas fait
défoncer comme ça qu enfin pas dire j'ai
pas perdu mais j'ai versé et là c'est
quand même fou france et quatre
prochains tu fais 3 m2 juste pour
montrer un faux france et 4,8 adam ne
peut pas rester au contrôle de la tour
tu dégages abandon des charges
abandonnées monde mais pas non plus que
ce pc alors je suis côté car le cnca
l'ordinateur a dit tu mérites coiffe un
but des cats et prendra les commandes
mais c'est ça ta grande tarte à gros
bide toi lui dit soit fait moins bien
que toi kevin est bon il fait des trucs
avec a et b 3 pour empêcher ces 5 1 et
tonton ouais mon pote tu empêches répond
plein mais carlson il a défoncé ding
il va défoncer sommet hockey contre
gritche normalement mardi a d'ailleurs
les mecs le match femmes on m'a dit que
c'était mardi le juge d'un tube
la roumanie c'est magnus six qualifiés
normand c'est mardi donc c'est dans
trois jours et l'acquis degree choo que
des ombres de vlad et qui dit ombre de
vlady ça va être chaud du caleçon ce
match un fab bas à l'année dernière
avant les bullet il y avait que plus en
plus deux pour manu ce fait un jargon tu
vois et je crois qu'il a public triment
pour nom maigrichon que face à ces
quelques parties glisse rim de loin tu
vois pas ce que vlad de fatwas donc il a
vu là grob très bonne partie de la zone
difficile on est très en retard par
rapport à la partie et dans le futur et
je reste quand même à trois secondes un
vrai mais c'est la latence après c'est
normal après tout pas obligé de notre
grande richesse comme prêtre que suivra
juste sur le stream ici allais-je des
cages passait comme un mec qu'au stade
de foot par rapport à d'autres ont tâté
des décalages comme avant à la télé
question qui du coup je me dis toujours
oui il ya un décalage avec tuerie sur
mon site avec le calendrier exact crise
crise you parce qu'en fait ces enjeux
souvent le calendrier j'ai pas mis à
jour
je le ferai non mais changent tout le
temps devant votre dur de ce dur à
suivre donc
c'est pavla d'un qui commentera mardi
mais peut-être y aura une surprise mardi
favreau commentaire c'est toi qui est
sur le coup moi bon on verra je pense
que j'adore ça ce soir on s'est sans
doute et en termes de lots se serait
même au dessus de vlad fin ça a été au
dessus de la ddt
ça va ramener du ski on verra donc fap
cette position finalement structure de
française sans le foot cases blanches
pour les noirs est ce que the way sli
n'aurait pas égalisé bas mais tape
encore rockets quoi de dire où va ton
rock mais je suis obligé de roquettes
yeux pas faire fouet cette tour g8 g5
fui dans l'espoir que je suis retourné
en c4 mais bon là je fais juste
attention
du coup il te fait des pions doublant ou
trois ils te rock auquel assure flashy
c'est quoi l'idée sacrifice d'un
positionnelle qui avait par exemple tu
dégages non je pense found me donner son
nom mais la sauge à lui il va prendre
deux heures il va faire 4 ne sais pas ok
mais non ne peuvent pas les blancs ne
peuvent pas être mieux ici falchi il
peut le dire je sais pas s'ils le sont
derrière marc frot 5e prend dé 5,7
gestion dans le 3ème set puis on prend
petits clous et c'est un truc pour les
tontons qui regarde
l'ordinateur l'ordinateur il en
profondeur 16-17 c'est à dire que
l'ordinateur comprend moins bien la
position à l'heure actuelle que fabien
il va juste voir les erreurs tactiques
plus rapidement mais sinon fabien a un
oeil plus plus pointu que stockfisch à
profondeur 16 donc c'était juste pour le
diable c'est quand même important
je remettrai de voitures pointeur de ton
oeil est quand même très très
impressionnante n'avait aucun problème
c'est qu'ils ont été entassées juste
plus ou moins légales mais bon ok tu
peux être moi bien un truc c'est finale
retour ont tous relevé faiblesse le lac
sécurité durant importante et le roi
noir est quand même moins en sécurité à
long terme que laura blanc maintenant
peut-être que tu réussis jamal touché
puisque trop d'activités pour les noirs
ouais perceptive et les blancs d'oeufs
battus faire dame b 3 h quelque chose
toro un terme à des couloirs qui vont se
taper un peu aussi ce genre mais
peut-être tour soit troisième en g3 dam
des trois pattes fait des petits trucs
par ci par là tu posteras tel beldame
taille et doigté que tu peux faire des
choses quoi après est-ce que ça suffira
dur à dire que vous étiez des noirs est
très intéressante alors qu'ils soient
qui demande si on peut enlever
l'estimation stock stockfisch alors on
va à l'essai pour une simple raison
c'est qu'on essaye avec avec chasse
comme de d'allergie re d'allah jir
pardon un maximum le public qui peut
suivre des échecs d'où ce format qui est
plus un format gaming est donc dans un
souci d'accessibilité on va essayer de
garder le la petite barre pour que les
gens qui passent voilà deux sur twitter
qui voit un scream déchets qu il puisse
avoir à gauche la barre et savoir qui
est mieux en fait ce qui est pas mal et
tout en vous disant aussi que l'oeil
aguerri de fable qui est bon fab en
profondeur 47
là on est sur du fab 2.0 qui tourne tu
tournes sur quoi tu tournes sur un msi
gamer bon il faut le dire était sur un
alienware et donc fable sur un alienware
ça fait très très mal
c'est beaucoup mais cette blague tu t'es
dit ya une utilité ils en sortent
toujours des nouvelles c'est de plus en
plus un [ __ ] de dix jours pour rien
je suis pas obligé de laisser leur dire
si j'ai envie d'enlever le redis je
l'enlève 1 personne ne m'oblige à rien
fait de toute façon dont j'espère comme
ne nous oublie jamais à rien mais mais
je suis d'accord avec la philosophie du
truc en fait donc vu que je suis en
accord avec ce qui est dit je fais si
j'étais pas un accord je ne sais pas
assez attention ne prend pas le pion à
432,8 ya vraiment fait ils vont ramener
à déranger 5 comme ça ya plus de vingt
ans g2 ils y affèrent tour eiffe un
machin mieux c'est dur à dire quoi fin
ça semble pas si simple que pour les
normands madame g simple g5 sepa couple
messe d'hommage site sans plus
il s'agit du projet 6 paszek donc la
foire d'échangé 6 quand même j'imagine
et puis il va y avoir de la faim tour a
fui lhassa à la tour va s'activer du coi
absent car le sait il est là il se marie
en train de sourire et un très très
content c'est rare et un regard sur ce
sera le bal à l'étude à deux tours
complètement nul mais tu es fou times et
oursins la source et 7
ça doit être un japon c'est tellement
j'avais pu temps c'est un pauvre en
trois ans et sept bateaux sont bons du
coup le mec 10 rebonds ballet
convalescence et je vais dans les faits
à huy stratégie comme ça avec dauphin
même tiens moi je vends bien même comme
ça je peux pas l'enlever 7 c'est
beaucoup plus intelligent la tour f
[Rires]
alors qu'elle tourne bien non mais il
est en train de le masser la fin un
petit mais ça c'est fantastique comme
des cinq tombes et 6 jean moulin il est
souple 1 il est en train de se marrer en
train de regarder je pense qu'ils
regardent en face à son passif et tu
veux pas jouer à ma place sur quelques
coups à ayew 80e 4 échecs jamais bien
joué de la part de west est quand même
fin
non d'hommes siens oui je vais vous tuer
adams et 8 le mal de l'escalier
spécialistes internes a rompu à faire
damner fuite le tarn et en russie ça va
et si la tour se barde fait d'un
psychiatre échecs passés
c'est chiant que tout était ok badham
ses catéchèses attention qui fait une
blague que je n'arrive pas à comprendre
sookie enso a pas mal wahou la blague de
tarse werder est hyper film quoi so i
ain't so wesley so i ain't so c'est une
blague je pensais avec une bague avec
well well wesley quoi faf
je pense qu'il ya une blague à ses fines
en langue et la maintenance ou fait
reconnu d'emploi dommage
dès qu'on se barre bon second tour un
rush de e4 et choc est sûre j'ai trois
bombes un opéra deux échecs toutes nos
voitures mater nous mêmes
attends je montre un sur dame sait qu'à
3 h 8 damev sept tours à 3 h 2 le cas
des trois dames des dommages mais le
club d'amsterdam s'est un temps pisté
cudi l'échelle le côté non c'est une
musique féliciter une blague strictement
la rue quoi mais en fait j'ai pensé à un
truc ça fait penser à un truc en fait
qui que j'ai que voilà j'étais je suis
complètement à la rue en fait non je ne
connais pas cette chanson mais ils
bougent c'est quand même vachement c'est
un autre truc désolé mec
allez c'est un jeu de mot entre wesley
et wayne en fait
well well well dames et fuite
bon mais même temps sans fond cette
notion fadam les cinq tours à un rush de
24h avec moi perdu le set final on ne
comprend pas ce coup
déjà la montre n'a réellement est ce que
je vais tour c'est cette fois tu peux
jouer n'importe quand votre nom en fait
j'ai compris pourquoi je dois faire
mieux ici enfin je pense que je suis
mieux en fait avec les blancs voient pas
ça en fait car il regarde il regarde un
truc derrière l'écran de l'ordinateur
mais deux buteurs je sais pas je pense
que les mecs qui font des grimaces
derrière et qui sont intéressés de
descendre à 4 6 4 stop
oui mais tu fais hkd suivent un tien et
vous voyez un match à haut débit et puis
tu montres leroy vers f3 et enfin
bancaire ou f2 royal 3 kg 5h 4h est
direct et 3 et s'est mué en fait c'est
un peu fini comme çà la partie de max
aujourd'hui nos réseaux rejouer la même
vente de spagnol que dans le match là il
a quelques-uns matches le champion du
monde un lion d'argent larhantec foods 6
to salon moi je crois et mais en fait je
suis arrivé qu à la fin en fait j'ai
pavé j'ai pas pu voir à l'ouverte chose
que sur voir le chase n'arrive pas à
voir les coups avant en fait ça m'énerve
non mais il ya d'autres trucs qui aura
d'où tu peux voir parfaite latchès
points quand même très très bien ce que
tu as à l'analyse de l'ordi en plus mais
bon enfin pour votre preuve d'autant de
clown ou non mais ok mais le mec va
jouer avec l'option jarre que même la
défense passive marche vers vous pouvez
juste faire ainsi pour le pion le plus
rage contre le port du voile est la tour
en f1 et attendent avec le tour un arbre
à gien et du fait nul avec le pion j'ai
ça suffit d'invoquer serre que le mec
est à -1 et il joue déjà la montre bush
mais de lutter c'est déjà de the citizen
se joue la montre donc en fait il a
juste peur de se faire ridiculiser
donc l'europe on va tous les mecs je
pense qu'ils écoutent le stream vise bon
bah on va faire tous les averses de ce
qu'il raconte sa plastique 3 tient axel
smith point d'exclamation
trois hommes trois noms d'oiseaux
foisonnent au sis en face aux merlus 1
pour dire c'est dans un bouquin qui est
sortie jusqu'au litige sheth écrit par
axel smith et le mec est très content
d'eux 3 donc je remonte la position au
mans 2-3 oui satan ferme le fou c'est un
mets très bon coup il met un point
d'exclamation et très heureux de ce coup
et nous évidemment ben enfin en tant que
fan des trucs les plus idiots possible
enfin ça nous a tout de suite plu fab
lab a provoqué la ligne assez connue
depuis longtemps ça s'appelle la rente
cause du 14 mai juste en fait une toute
intrusion assez peu joué mais qui
revient peu lama de krav nicklas jouer
des joueurs comme ça moi même a
peut-être à nantes s'était coincée
karake lalande je crois dans aux
candidats la dernière fois qu'ils
avaient trois des cinq outre au deuxième
donc ok c'est pas si mal mais moi
j'avais beaucoup plus dense dans le iii
au premier est bientôt
[Musique]
voilà voilà du coup souvent en fait on
ne soit joué avec ses 4 comme il l'a
fait soit joué avec 4 avec les blancs
mais là ok tu peux jouer contre les
pions pendant prenant un point à ses
cinq et ont formé deux pas mal placée en
fait le fou en bd en fait il vit dans un
deuxième temps là il est plus si
renfermé que ça en fait manqué noir ont
fessé 5 pour contrer le centre ce cas un
jour ou l'autre ça c'est changer le fou
s'ouvrant comme ça le foot les deux
hommes était potentiellement
intéressants
dames b5 j'aime bien ta proches tadam
pas mal ce coup peut-être tu faire là
déjà tu mets nation française cinq
femmes et tu peux plus prendre du plomb
est obligé de faire un pur isolé ouais
ok c'est 7,5 ou mecquois down the shins
battant est-ce que baisser bbc avait
annoncé avec l'idée pions prend et c6 ça
peut être maintenant un genre je fait
baisser tu fais feu je fais c'est 6 me
naughty bear alors dit que ces gagnants
ils ne l'avaient pas vu mes bd c'est un
refus de reprendre une personne oui mais
ok mais pas impuni zoo les high la fédé
c'est un jouet ou nam ok tu peux pas
dire que les blancs sont pas mieux fab
d'un bug et enfin tu peux le dire si tu
envie mais tu diras juste un homme ok
mais ça va
j'ai le 3 non mais évidemment tu peux
dire ce que tu veux enfin je ne censure
pas quoi mais mais l'intention d'arriver
elle ce soit la bm vl oui vif qui jouent
pas ils pourraient mener à lui de
soissons ses intentions nous sortons les
drapeaux même j'ai retrouvé de peluches
de footix qui prêchent supporter enfin
oui tout cela n'aura temps là est ce que
ce serait pas qu'est-ce qui se passe
l'ordinateur pas content non mais ses
djs quoique ils ont recréé un match à
tora de speech s de 1917
une fois que c'est il faut jouer des
pronostics d'ordi quoi alors les gens
qu'en huitièmes de finale il ya émue
elle aimait les lascars contre les films
bogoliubov tarte à coverciano ski club
blanca contre leicester aaron niveau de
vie contre marc au xix de l'autre côté
du tableau tu as ta rage contre marshall
spillmann contrat liqin grünfeld contre
eti aimiez this content robin stein
c'est chaud quoi alors bon ben la spière
a massacré bon goût du golfe valmir 5
ennemis par contre eu très très chaud en
partageant nos skis 15me 14 et 9 ans
pour tartas cover aussi chaud capable en
cas gagné largement 17 ennemis neuf et
demi contre leicester nino judge a gagné
19 12 combats roxy et donc on a des
cartes finale de ce petit tableau l'as
caire car sa cover est capable en cas
d'exode itx qui c'est génial de leur
côté robin steinbach vieillissent valmy
cet ennemi rétive à greenfield 19,9 elle
et qui n'a gagné 20 13 secondes speedman
et un match très très chaud entre
marchal et arrache ce jeu beaucoup la
montre 14 et demi très et demi mais si
elle examine marche annoncée je sors un
grand marshall dans leur antre de chess
de la dernière
mon pote mais tu trouves ça ou la fab je
sais pas j'ai vu les images que je la
partage rac
non mais attends mais comment comment on
n'a pas commenté sa faim ça m'a l'air
d'être encore enfin sam allardyce face à
valère d'aller encore plus loin si tu
veux enfin des fois je me dis c'est la
réalité dépasse la fiction quoi alors du
coup attend juste les demi-finales du
speech et 1917 c'est capable en callas
caire et notre côté robin stein et les
kids c'est chaud je pense que ça va
faire un capable en cas les kills de
folie en bas c'est le fameux match où on
veut que des grandes dames quoi mettre
un peu de thé c'est déjà une voix tant
mieux
non mais attendez ce que tu es en train
de dire fable c'est enfin pour moi c'est
l'info de la soirée pour le mur face est
génial non m 16 points comme c'est trop
des génies sur certains trucs mais
attends mais car c'est en train de se
faire des façons quoi il faut s le game
of thrones non attends mais attends mais
quand où on a raté sa nou où on est et
où quand ça se passe et ce truc
non mais je pense et les ordis qui ont
dû faire tout seul je jouais pas quoi
qui le lien du tweet tweet ont déjà tout
ça c'est le truc le game of thrones non
match perdu par ma connexion mais c'est
trop dessus est obligé d'aller du
courage aux horaires élargis maggie ça
va venir des excuses de 1917
on s entend trop tard non mais attends
c'est franchement s'ils refont ça chaque
année mais moi je veux commenter ça
l'année prochaine même s'il attend je
veux non mais ok mais tu fais comme
c'est des génies mais il sait qu'il ya
le sia le cio de check point com qui a
fait un live mais qui bouillait tâche à
ce point comme la sphère la bbc mais des
ihm et des masques complètement débile
fantastique la cdg leetchi.com en fait
mais les gens ne le savent pas il le
match plus trop si on guérit de le
douzième coup d'avoir cette vie-là du
dit merci pour le live ben je vous ai
mis les liens la destruction plus tard
bon bref regardez mon dans cette partie
fab
non mais c'était quand même une info oui
c'est important quoi comment et l'ordi
qua non mais c'est une info j'ai pas
assez gros baisse que tu as un truc
alors du coup cette pause montfa boon
est bon je sais pas des recettes pour la
gueule me mouille pas quoi non ok mais
s'il est blanc récupère des cadres de
nous voir un pion isolé je pense qu'une
position à pure isolé je pense qu'ils
vont récupérer des quatre quand même à
terme objets des cavaliers oui je lâche
une foule là je suis un faux couple
énorme échange des cavs a dit non en
fait je pense que les blancs ils vont
faire genre dame prend des quatre
maintenant où il va faire flouer eux
deux il va jouer plus optimistes est ce
qu'on peut elle faire gros rock ou très
optimistes bah voilà voilà un truc
intéressant mais en fait j'ai perdu 10,4
en fait pas tout bêtement fait tous
notre nom mais là ça m'a pas l'air
d'être super pour les bleus enfin j'veux
pas d'âme à 5 c 5 fu aussi soudé si ça
va vite quand même moi je ne sais pas
enfin la france au moment où les noirs
doivent être un peu mieux fin je me fie
à l'ordinateur aussi un petit peu aussi
mais enfin leur disque où ça me
déconcentre pour analyser mais là quand
même la taxe noir va plus vite fin damas
cinq à non j'ai changé d'âme bas j'étais
pas mal je prends ta dam je fais à 3
je crois bien d'ailleurs ou à 3 tours
détours tourner autour h 20 je fais je
mets mon rendez de gchangetout quoi ai
je fait nul marois d2 alors rendez vous
phare théâtre et jouer sur le clouage
bas ok je fais tourcoing 8 et tour tu
vas tu obligé de faire [ __ ] en f3 je
vais jouer avec les pions double en f3
je vais faire nul dans cette finale
enfin sur un pion à pas s'éloigner
d'ailleurs un moment donné barnum et on
prend 8 tours à grady senio notre fou
lâché la colonne je pense avec les noirs
faut garder les tours est faux de dire
je n'ai pas vu une personne
non franchement ça j'aurais pas j'aurais
jamais joué homme edmond cellules sur
111 sûrement égal mais nul c'est autre
chose
une défense me suis régalé une position
qui sera forcément nul ou d'être gros en
fait la position de base des échecs elle
est déjà égalant façon réfléchie avant
le premier coup on imagine peut-être que
les blondes gagneraient où les noirs
j'avais un père guy d'amnésie c'était
horrible grèce sont des pas le coup le
plus ambitieux de la carrière de sauver
bon sur les coups ambitieux s'est pas
conclu mais pas non plus réputés pour
les coûts ambitieux sorte ce nom m'a
appris la dgre aux prépas et du coup
quand il sort sa grosse paie pas il peut
te tu vois non mais sow le truc il te
ramasses à la cuillère quand tu fais des
erreurs et il lui je vous prends tu peux
faire des ronds regroupant sais pas
comment dire mais c'est la direction que
ça donne c'est mécanique
et moi je n'apprécie pas le style de jeu
particulièrement quoi mais mais bon peu
importe ça ça reste un truc qui marche
bien il était extraordinairement fort
dans les 2016 l'ac thann et ça marche
moins bien mais bon il reste aux
alentours de 1800 lots donc je veux dire
le mec est très très fort nous on est
loin enfin surtout moi je dirais
je n'oublie pas ta punchline chalard
vaudrait mais oui oui oui mais du coup
là c'est important de comprendre que a4
a5 ça peut arriver à tout moment
start i avait plus les tours et tous
âges en finale de rois aux actionnaires
on en parlait hier pendant les master
class 1 2 ça peut toujours penser au
final deux pions c'est hyper important
est là en finale deux pions le pur à
passer ça peut être un fin il a une tête
de vainqueur lui c'est un marcheur blanc
bon ok pour l'instant une autre côté du
mur mais ce qui deviendra et b5 bien
joué ils soulignent la faiblesse du pion
des 5 et les quatre hommes ya plein de
gens qui pensent que manu se regardent
la télé en même temps ou qui regardent
quelque chose il est très souvent la
tête pour regarder un truc qui se passe
derrière l'écran
bapt west ham qui jouent en direct sur
ça je vais regarder
c est ce qu il ya ce qui est du foot
anglais selon magnus joue truc très très
important c'est la fantasy league le
championnat anglais tu sais pas si vous
connaissez un peu pareil tu connais on
pensait que connaissent pas fait si tu
fais tu as ton équipe de foot tu as un
budget de jaar 100 millions mais ça
c'est chaque joueur les joueurs ont une
certaine valeur qui évoluent en fonction
des résultats et leurs performances
réelles de chaque week end
et donc voilà donc tellement elle
transfère par semaine à un bref faut
faire un tri compos et donc familier une
tactique là parce que l'ordi plus de 14
et roy b3 le magnat torah êtes tour à
tour est enfermé tuant fermer ta propre
retour n'a remarqué mais ça c'est quand
même des grosses erreurs à ce niveau-là
fabre oui mais c'est ok il faut faire b5
seul coup et maintenant comment est-ce
qu'on se débrouille toi te fait pire
j'allais dire qu'on v5 soit pour tous
mais peut-être francs b5 manon ouimet
cavalli prend reprend quelques réponses
et 3 contres fourche à 3,5 qui prendrait
un refrain à six mois qu'ils allaient
bien mais je pense qu'ils gagnent enfin
peut-être commencer par tour un échec
alors voilà vous [ __ ] en bessin qui
prend b5 tourer un échec
et après
le second répond très facile de savoir
quand l'ordi mais enfin voyais ses sauts
grosse erreur le mec mais ok il est puni
quelque part tu es puni pour dames b6 qu
irina palois n'en avait pas le droit de
joie mais non mais femmes t'as pas le
droit d'échanger des dames quant à une
grosse attaque
je remonte le bronx que ça m'énerve a
échoué derby c'est sa part à 2-2 qui au
regard de manchester newcastle
moi je ne sais pas non mais en fait tu
l'as marck durant la partie
ok les noirs on la vend sur l' attaque
le roi c'est un ok déjà à colombes et
ouverte il ya la dame qui peut vous
allez devenir en a cinq la tour en baby
ton sens qu'on va mener une attaque
rapide tête emmené ses cinq c4 ces trois
mêmes on va rapide sur le roi de l'autre
côté le roi blanc on est quand même loin
de faire j'ai quatre coups de la grotte
à 14 coups de retard est du coup assez
logique de garder les dames parce qu'on
est une attaque rapide bon la finale et
peut-être encore très correct mais bon
il ya déjà quasi plus et un pour les
noirs et aux caisses avance avance
avance était puni cal et prend bessengue
la magnus tels fabien libye zf ce qu'ils
ont sont plus grand jour aujourd'hui à
l'école selon lui ouais ça joue bien
c'est là que 8,3 d'habitants pour pour
les blocs qua non mais c'est vrai dire
ce n'est pas l'équipe de france quoi
faire alors il ya trois partout là je
suis en train de shekels au score 10-10
les y accéder sur trois partout là bas
moi j'ai l'intrigué 3,8 pourquoi non
juste mais à 3 3 ghz et clymène et sa
voix le on met ça face qu'ils écrivent
l'équipe oui mais mais oui non mais
c'est pas enfin j'ai relu sais c'est pas
le villarreal le sporting gijon et que
l'école
du coup en fait si je pensais qu'ils
allaient faire flouer f1 pour sécuriser
même pas aidé à se plonger de il pousse
trop vite il va faire c'est ça qui va
encaisser le pur f5 et méo quelle sauce
et quand même faute professionnelle ce
truc de dames b6 déjà ne faisait il pas
content de la part d' évaluation lille
c'est nul allez lui ici en début de
seconde mi temps dit un soldat qui suit
le match la jeune fille dort ici je suis
là c'est didier salut digne et merci
pour tout et partager tout et like
pouces bleus de remercier les pouces
bleu symboles pouces bleus pour didier a
moqué mets vins chers wesley s'il a si
peur que ça m'est fait des ruines quoi
arrête de te torturer quoi joue ruiz
ruiz ruiz quoi
non mais je pense que c'est juste enfin
c'est juste la peur qui l'a fait jouer à
madame b 6 en fait je pense qu'il n'a
pas du tout le bon la bonne approche
mentale
moi je sais pas ben moi en tout cas
c'est pas comme ça qu'il peut gagner le
match mais c'est faux lâche été coup je
sais pas trois revers non mais ok mais
sinon t'as aucune chance à contre bas
déjà de base je donne de très faibles
chances mais bon on sait encore moins
bah non mais il faut il faut lâcher ses
coups faut tout tenter et fâché parce
comme quand tu joues contre contre un
mec plus fort que toi dans n'importe
quel sport il faut tenter
ok bon là c'est quand même dangereux ce
que fait ma nuit sans il al'argent ce
n'est pas largué un pion mais son pion
des hakkas c'est soupçonnant tu pas un
truc comme eux trois ça peut déjà trois
épreuves dont 3 quelles preuves de ces
beaux arts je montre donc trois avec
l'idée de s'en prendre aux pions des cas
parce qu'il est cloué donc du coup on
veut le manger elle a en fait fallu dix
cavaliers problème de menaces la tour
apprend à f2 tient purement et trois
échecs
c'est moi qui ai montré ce monde réviser
mes valises et je ferai attention et ce
qu'est ce que d'ailleurs faut dire qu'à
saint-etienne à sainté en fait on appel
on appelle fab son surnom c'est l'aigle
de saint-etienne alors tourner tous les
stéphanois le savent pas je répondis
l'agglo de santé agents n'y a pas d'avis
que ça ici fabien 19,6
mais ces trois vont s'allonger que
masquer prendre deux ou trois noms mais
jean-guy d'apprendre parquet local
pourront faire derrière cinq dames au 7
mai elle est pas mal avec de taille
alors moi je comprends en terre si je
pense à un truc un délire avec l'adm et
sauces et paca fc parce que c'est pas
sogood je reviens je vais faire comme
prendre un élément au caire c'est
peut-être ça joue tout de même regretter
le manque déjà de pions je ne sais pas
aucune preuve des six armes et deux
pions pour la kalach ça va il faut
bouger le caractère faire kamal b5 nom
est allé vers eux ok ok mais l'écart est
vite quand même qui est prise prise tour
vite
ah non pas du tout cas m6 pour château
et mais bien du tout du goût c'est pas
clair du tout quoi c'est pas mal pour
les branchements mais tu sais qu'il ya
la pieuvre qui arrivait sur b6000
cavaliers doivent trois heures et donc
ok c'est pas simple de sortir sur pc
c'est le cas mais c'est clair que
carlson ils regardent la télé en même
temps c'est obligé irinej trop la tête
comme quand tu regarde la télé ils
regardent le foot il regarde un truc je
pense vraiment qu'il y nouvelle star en
norvège en son nom je ne sais pas où un
koh lanta norvégien mais niveau football
ce soir hier le rugby bon les blacks ne
consacrera pas de large soit ils
regardent mais le rugby de france qui
regarde tout ça mais je sais pas moi de
dire non plus car manchester newcastle
pour sa part ça j'ai pas d'idée on peut
regarder non mais on regarde quelque
chose ils regardent trop souvent vers
là-bas et s'il regarde une télé c'est
sûr ou alors ils regardent au public
leur est possible nouvelle série sur
netflix
ouais le premier épisode je suis dedans
moi je vais m'abonner à netflix their
aujourd'hui c'est facile et je pense
qu'ils vont tout dire non non ne vient
pas on n'est pas la fibre n'ont fait
très attention enfin je te sens je sens
que taquiner avec la fibre et sinon
parce le drame s'il va sortir de real en
fait si il a des coups d'envoi deux fois
déjà je crois mais mais c'est ce soir le
derby de madrid entre le real et
l'atlético là en ce moment ça joue pas
donc le roux ont peut-être qu'ils
regardent et m'écoutent s'échauffer et
j'en sais rien mais pas ceux qui se
passionnent pour un échauffement
non mais ce qui est hallucinant je sais
pas mais c'est sûr qu'il regardait un
truc tu as l'impression que enfin c'est
tellement facile contre euro et c'est
que tu regarde la télé en même temps
quoi je vous confie 6e mondial ce soir
j'ai mis un match bon mais quand même ne
serait pas si simple proposition enfin
je pense que même s'ils perdent on bat
trois pions pour la call of ça c'est à
dire énorme et b4 que 28 tu va lancer
l'étude du coup il ya une utilité à la
caméra femme c'est de voir que magnus
regard de téléphone non mais c'est sympa
pour les spectateurs
alors même avec un quart d'attention je
suis plus de toit il me demande ce qu'il
faisait pendant que je compte toile au
speech est ce que tu étais sûr mais je
me disais je me disais il prend trop la
confiance fab
il va la sortir tôt ou tard et je
l'attendais depuis déjà minimum dix
minutes celle là je me disais il va me
la sortie rimaye comment ça va me sortir
une blague de blaye 3 punch and call
punchline et en plus si c'est que pour
le prochain match de ce pitch est si
c'est bon il c'est fini tu utilises et
qu'ils risquent plus rien femmes quatre
au free la confiance son ton
ça fait rire les gens non le vaccin de
sa petite soeur en fait en plus à
masquer sa petite soeur je pense
attention à ce que tu dis c'est très
très fort si je ne te censure pas mais
je vais faire très attention à ce que tu
vas d'irlande à la proie de bon la
victoire de wesley
voilà la ligne plus attendent at talah
il est bon dans ce genre structure
manière ferme et que tu veux que je te
dise un truc et on vous rappelle quand
et si chez moi vlada m'a parlé d'un truc
et je ne veux pas te dire oui c'est
vraiment ça tu te jure l'ombre de vlad
plane sur tous les matches en fait c'est
une nouveauté dans cette ligne il était
très fier je sais plus ce que c'est
exactement mais c'était dans cycling et
c'est à peu près cette position était
très content mais magnus en fait avait
déjà plus ou moins nous a justement
conduit de windhoek l'an dernier nenê a
trouvé à se voter quelque part mais on
va être juste il aime bien jouer les
positions de ces structures
[Musique]
carlsbad
c'est ça la carte son intégrée toi tu
génères quels grands maîtres
internationaux un cake ce champion du
monde joue très mal les structures
carlsbad
je réfléchis donc ils ces informations
là non c'est pas beau mais il joue
encore de minces des montants non actu
enfin il est pas sur le mensonge sur ce
fait magnus mais sur le second je sais
pas quoi dire crowded house aux normes
quelqu'un de ma famille qui joue très
bien c'est pas une taxe est pas un troll
il ya un ex-champion du monde
qui joue très mal et ce truc sauce
carlsbad vichea n'en ai d'ailleurs de
l'adm a sorti la est sorti une
excellente punchline il m'avait leader
je considère qu'ils ne jouent pas mieux
que 2003 cette position paris veut dire
en compréhension
mais il m'a dit qu'il devait pas donner
votre lame êtres humains mais il m'a dit
tu ne verra quasiment jamais une
structure carlsbad dans une partie d'un
an
elle va toujours habité pour toujours et
m'a dit si tu peux le pied en cette
structure a de grandes chances rugles
même toit vous voyez c'est ça n'est ni
même toi tu peux 20 médocs et tu vas
perdre apprécié à te défoncer les mêmes
toi tu ne comprends pas moins bien pour
te dire à quel point le mec est une [ __ ]
ok mais là c'est très beau ce qui est en
train de faire magnus et le beau jeu
quoi tour 3 h quatre tours h3c l'esprit
on finirait par les options de ce jour
grande chat qui fait des rimes je suis
pour sow non mais c'est parce qu'ils
sont ok il ya cinq six points à
connaître en fait non mais en fait
qu'aucune et de couleurs enfin mais
auquel chacune magnus lada fin avec les
blancs et joue bien je dégaine souvent
ces carreaux calme comme ça mais en fait
sur le faire je laisse truc avec les
blancs perso j'ai toujours du mal à
faire la tacc de minorités tout fin je
comprends jamais vraiment où ça mène
c'est trop abstrait point semaine
quelque part en contre non mais joe g
100 kg est un pion un pion faible en c3
le mec me défonce le roi et puis la fin
mai claque un fameux exemple sölden
c'est un choix conduit par mes mots mais
non en fait de raccroc cette histoire de
d'attac de minorités c'est un truc qu'on
lit c'est trop abstrait c'est un peu
comme le livre de nîmes 2 800 systèmes
quoi ça tu sais quand tu es petit machin
mais c'est un peu une recette de cuisine
ouais tiens je te fais b4 b5
tu as un pion faible chez atac je gagne
le ghana finale mais en fait le match
tourne pas les pouces en face ray en
fait j'ai même pas sûr que ce soit si
important le chèque moderne tout cas
déjà vu des parties modèle j'analyse
avec leurs dix avec le pion faible
lancer six la cantina grand la c6 oui
oui c'est 6
mais en fait leur nid te tiens ça même
la fameuse position que tu dois gagner
parce que tu as le bon rapport matériel
mach a fait montre leur dis tu l'a
gagnée par jamais le maintien tout en
fait oui j'ai 4 dommage mais peut-être
arriver g41 fait très attention
jean cayrou h saint cloud prend dès 8
ans quand des 8 j 4 kelly et 6 d'un
machin vous qu'allez vous feront le voir
s'arrêter
voilà l'ordinateur de +35 ans non les
mecs ce qui en fait sa sortie est quand
même assez faible pour choix plus fort
que lui il faut quand même soit pas très
fort et tu as décidé de te calmer là si
on y travaille et je t'ai cendres -
taquin la darse et que c'est cette
affiche qui a gagné le tournoi il a
battu d'un mâchon roger 2 3g de tours à
charge je pense qu on a le temps de
machin c'est juste le le beau jeu mais
bon rage et de ses symboles à mehdi
houas tiers d'un machin mayroy g2j joue
très bien mais en fait le risque c'est
que le plus étroit et très bien protégé
par la dame est l'atout en fait juste un
oui enfin c'est fait mais bon enfin
comment tu les attaques et donc du coup
ce n'est pas fun mais c'est une de tes
phrases d'avoir ta phrase tour hlm 1 3
ne tient pas mal d'amis est plongée
s'invite le manger
qu'ils allaient prendre le pion c3 mais
ce qui me contre dame française trois
peut-être a tant apporté papillon 3e cat
oui je protège ma dame avec la tour le
français 3e attaque la dame et je veux
faire ça et au ketchup 4 et je voudrais
aux trophées tour c'est un pour défendre
de trucs louches peuvent calculer c'est
tout les dames projet cinq sont un peu
normal dans le procès trois tours h1n1
échec engrangé 3 1 se cache tranquille
et le roi de la douane france et 3 ok
mais d'un projet et tu n'as plus des
chèques non avec les noirs on va être
échangé 3ème élu parce qu'elle sent ici
sinon roi de la grob ya des roses grow
up de tous les côtés ah c'est pas mal
parce que si tu fais ton tour prends tu
pourras pas prendre des quatre à cause
de cavaliers c6 fourchette royal et si
tu feras reprend bas juste pas d'un
projet s'attaque aux cavaliers je gagne
un temps tous deux ont leurs stocks
fiche arrive à 18 en profondeur ben moi
je la 19 là il monte un peu plus haut
des fois mais c'est très très bien le
truc café à tchatche.com très pratique
et aux années ligne ils se donnent tous
c'est génial
on est combien là dans le live ya je ne
sais pas mettre un petit message en
discorde
j'espère qu'on ait au moins 253 sans fin
chez payot pour les partages et venir
suivre le live avec magnus tête tout
reproche six échecs la boue et je repars
d'ici je prends aussi très bien c'est
bien des 360 pendant soixante ça va vous
êtes bien battus à léon montaut 500 ce
soir allez les dicodeurs reviennent au
score 10 à 15 1 coutard zolder oui les
échos c'est beaucoup plus fort que
l'équipe de france bon comment comment
termine plein je les perds tu reprends
ici ces dames premier fui thatta préfet
qui a aidé ici s'il défend tout le
forgeron qui est content dans le
discours des bouleaux parties amicales
et gc ca et sur quelle g6 et la mettre
en regard dame prend et ouais c'est ça
qui me dit est vrai sont déjà là bas
sinon d'un coup marrant c'est qu'il y
ait des sept la merde mais de taille
applique attaque les dames on ne veut
pas faire d sûr de ça tu perds ça rigolo
enfin elle fait d'alger 5 et 6 dames g6
ça c'est subtil menacé de me prends je
te prends me fourchette est large et
adam déjà essayé de bouger bombe à géra
du temps pour faire un petit orage 7g
venir constater m dames h7 et dame des
sept matches encore mieux son poste
meneur d'hommes geste pour haïti
d'investisseurs assez classe c'est
mignon aïe je te défends 17 marocaine
défend je m'en fiche
mais un minimum qui avait 17 jan ferme
ta tour astral radio s'écoute tout
d'abord je le fais un rêve mais ça
tourne à plus de cases
échec et mat à la tour monsieur monsieur
je fais chaque et ma tasse à tour qui
est la portée philosophique l'heure
c'est trop philosophique pour moi là les
genres a tellement philosophie la master
class dire un cahier 17 c'est joli comme
coup ne tue pas il peut défendre
je suis spécialiste en partie à 1000
mètres de l'escalier monsieur c'est
fantastique
ces écoutes complot raté un les coûts
dame longue distance 5 minutes aurait
peut-être mieux fait de raismes écueil
c6 est obligé de faire passer 8 et
karelia 7 et sur tarn france et 6 1
metaleurop d'un problème et d'albin huit
dames ses huit bébés les six cavaliers
c'est cette dame dernier soit 8 to
russia libre at je suis dégâts alors
arrête heini adams et 7e entretenir mais
brave a fait un grand chose bah tour
contre calais prendre une décision oui
ouistes hong kong et même des six est
triple attaque je t'attaque tout et il
est content l'ama et l'uci d'arrêter de
regarder la télé d'ailleurs un étudiant
j'ai fait un bonne partie
bon maintenant je peux retourner voir la
télé c'est mon jeu de la marge si je
regarde la télé chez que plus un sou je
regarde ses comptes que les victoires
avec la télé je vais gagner le match
péniblement je vais finir là + 4
je suis très content de ça ils enfin se
marier la magnus très content et je suis
entre adriano stream des français j'ai
trente secondes de latence donc je vois
leurs réactions les connards on me dit
on me 20 secondes après dame et à
comprendre l'idée sur dame des cinq
d'entre eux vers ils sont vraiment nuls
même loterie dieu sont déjà visés non il
est en train de l'enregistrement et un
transfert ayant nagé fait nul contre lui
je respecte un peu mais l'autre
pauvrement tard gerba qui nous fait un
petit qui jugeaient le merci d'un jardin
ne pousse bleus pour taser pour le pour
le petit résumé rugby je fais plaisent
parce que je ne peux pas alors il nous
dit que les all blacks de replanter un
essai en infériorité numérique
c'est un peu comme magnus il ya hikaru
kama sutra qui élit bonjour mon livre on
joue aussi j'adore son pseudo en fait le
gall hikaru kama sutra génial j'adore
son esprit espiègle
r c'est une dédicace à h ça m'incite à
respirer ça ça fait un peu comme il l'a
de boom puis en français 5 b 5e ou non
bah non je n'ai donc notebook
c'est génial
est-ce que je commande france et afrique
du sud après les gervy en fait si
j'avais le dail les droits télé en fait
vous commenterez des matchs de rugby des
fois d'ailleurs on écrit roland garros
que oui mais on pourrait écrire à tous
roland garros mais très plastique
je regardais australie angleterre les
mec disait ça nous fait penser à une
partie d'échecs
jean où les regarder chez vous voir sa
durée dit quelque part on voit là
bonjour eux mêmes je crois bon on voit
des pièces pour des plaquages avec qui
court tout droit
bah oui enfin gérard le pion file à
l'essai quoi fin il va dans l'en-but
quoi tient la dame en train de faire un
plaquage cathédrale au food et de
l'attention voyez de mêler la plus en
mêlée mais tu as raison ça peut sembler
alors c'est un ballon porté
regarde un peu l'on partait à quatre
baies 5 complètement stoppée par par les
joueurs noirs qui se sont introduits
dans le ballon porté et une chose lui
poussait alors ménélik arles scène sert
d'introduction carlson on recommence la
partie ça tu prends les blancs c'est à
gagner leur production mais lise très
intéressant les échecs et b6 peut-être
en train de tuer toute l'amérique
ce ballon porté ne m'intéresse pas je
vais aller jouer de l'autre côté je fais
une passe au pied je change d'avis il
reste 33 le jeu elle en fait c'est
peut-être ça qui faisait manuscrits
regard des matchs de rugby pour faire
comprendre si on ferme les parties
d'esprit créatif
oui ça me fait penser une partie
d'échecs moi je m'inspirais mais du coup
c'est ça en fait ils regardent vraiment
vallée de nouveau en train de regarder
la télé ils regardent vraiment
all-blacks contre les egos exif je
m'inspire je dormais it richie regard du
rugby en même temps t'as pas le droit
tricheur d'ailleurs on n'a pas encore eu
la question mythique dans le chat qui
pesait qui peut être sûr que manu c'est
beaucoup malgré la caméra ne triche pas
vers le succès n'a pas encore eu cette
question mythique dans le chat qui
arrivent de temps on disait que contre
ceux qui regardent de rugby m
les regards des coups sur la ligne ter
en face en la gérant ne sais pas
c'est un maul c'est un ballon porté
d'ailleurs c'est un autre mot lenoir
tiens moi aussi je fais mon bol on joue
avec deux ballons sur le terrain je
tombais chacun à son ballon quel ballon
arrive en premier adam a laissé ensuite
leur fait gagner quand même genre de
compris quand il revient et demi sur un
an la plus simple à deux sur trois donc
réalisateur y avait une belle avec une
belle combinaison finale qu'on a vu en
live
ouais t'as bobby fischer 2 qui trollent
et les barons et j'avoue commencé qu'il
triche pas [ __ ] rabier je lui dis ce
que tu que je pose la question alors les
mecs vont ils se disent c'est comme la
mission a toujours un mec qui arrive
dans le chat avant pour la demande et à
les habituer dit c'est vrai qu'il nous
manque cette question pour nous énerver
tu vas faire un truc qui nous qui nous
chauffe
de quoi les femmes un compte avec des
chiffres de pertes ou de 8 7 6 8 0 11 2
ouah gros comme magnus il n'a pas triché
contre toi la question qu'on se pose
quand même s'il ya quand même sauvé sa
du lot a quand même on se dit tous les
doutes sont permis
heine three men en même temps par la
question
bon du coup bah du coup n'est pas d'égal
à détroit et j'envoie mon vin j'envoie
mon ballon à l'essai ouais ok ou en d 4
les cadets aux quatre coins vous prend
ben ouais mais comment est-ce qu'on
pousse à aller seule norme a tenté
d'aider quatre élus car je fais des
trois tiens tu prends ta dame qui me
prend madame tu te prends d'une prends
je prends ces quatre mountain casque de
protection magique où il a préparé
c'est peut-être mon nom mais maintenant
il faut un gars qui est fiancé quatre
ans f 4 f 4 octobre en tout coupe les
horaires autocool aux arriérés c'est ça
c'est des sujets chauds et des oreilles
on n'aime pas ça
il en train de se marrer car ça ils se
marraient ils écoutent encore il a fait
un signe du point genre on a gagné mais
c'est sûr ils regardent peut-être même y
avait un truc c'est sûr et si un match
qui vient de se terminer ou il ya un but
qui vient d'être marqué on va savoir ce
qu'ils regardent pas lorsque je croise
une vraie diva fâche résulte de nous
l'info c'est un très très heureux quoi
mais là point trop bon et du coup ça
choisi même si c'est fini c'est fini il
va pas me dire oui les gens qui a fait
un truc comme ça sur un truc important
instrument que les stars vient de
marquer un stand by
ces 4 1 il n'a marqué 71e et 72e bon bah
si vous dites que ce soit juste le
bouton j'espère qu'ils regardent le
match et faire ce que j'ai pu lutter et
comme luca quoi marque était de son
joueur de fantasy league indique le coup
en attaque gens simples enfin je
connaisse
j'ai des fois jouent vraiment c'est 3
juin d'amazon ou alors on a quelqu'un
qui joue dans sa ligue qua non mais
c'est sûr qu'il regarde un match de tout
un truc de sport ou parce qu'ils étaient
juste content d'un truc qui s'est passé
non monsieur je pense qu'il ya donc
j'espère qu'après 10 à guingamp amiens
c'est peut-être ça d'ailleurs bien que
manger attention le bahut coup d'envoi
nantes de granger sinon on va peut-être
que là ils exultent cause ou plus tard
du beau football ce soir j'ai chaud
entre dijon 3 entre guingamp et angers
strasbourg rennes ou toulouse m on se
régale avec haïti un coup attention un
psy montpellier lille tu veux qu'on en
parle très mal
je suis très inquiet pour le maintien ou
la tendance accrue de qualité c'est
chaud nam ok mais manu c'est quand même
fort c'est pas sérieux failli fait ce
qu'il veut mais c'est qu'elle ouvre
quand les mecs est juste en train de
regarder du sport à la télé enfin tf1
ben il chante des chansons de lukaku est
tout ok il ajustera athema lensois est
pas mal mais j'étais mal ici sauve
voyait que l'on est en train juste de
regarder un match de foot en même temps
faire écrit mais c'est démoralisant quoi
ouais ça tue le choix des zones et
lumière du mec
avez-vous manière c'est le calme
ok mais d'autres voix se renseigner et
tenter de jeu des trucs avec des pièges
et des trucs comme ça mail en train
c'est sa chance
il vient juste de gaffer une table un
coup en fait bas parce qu'ils pensaient
qu'ils aient pu reprendre et huit dames
et afu prend des huit femmes algériennes
énorme avec regarde la télé et où es-tu
gaffes des dames en un coût et il est
mort de rire la caresse salies se
marcquois dur ça y est les caisses qui
nul quoi bon train sur le mec est
vraiment nulle furieux enfin les
changent de chaîne surgelés zapper
pendant le match assez bien relou ah
tiens il refait lycée carnot scène qui
le fait peters était pas s'était passé
ou qui avait fait sert cette carte ça
déjà non mais je te dire sans régler
deux couleurs je te le fait d'être plus
fort même si ces trois usb 3 je te crois
moi mais ces fontaines fin franchement
c'est enfin ça montre à quel point il
est au dessus en fait ben non non ça va
mais je suis pas surpris mais à ce point
là enfin je sais pas tu te marche je
regarde la télé tu rigoles avec les gens
à côté tu te fout de sa gueule quand il
donne une dame en un coup enfin ça fait
quoi tu peux je suis contente par a
perdu contre lui fin satellitaire
humiliant mais surtout surtout il devait
très certainement regarder pas un match
mais deux matches de foot d'heure contre
le mans m3 et un multiplexe tient non
mais ok mais là il gagne une pièce en
suisse non on gagne un truc non mais la
pièce est en fait il va jamais la
reprendre en général et en bus et en
train de se marrer ailleurs rigole
encore oui ils regardent et l'azoté aie
fait des grimaces dans une courbe à ce
que le mec fait quoi tintin n'est donc
vraiment qu'ils arrêtent ce scrutin
jours dans la brousse peeters que le mec
en face à city pour avoir à faire et on
le voit même plus à l'écran payet sait
si ce fantastique sas de moteurs de
saisir non j'ai regardé la vidéo de
motivation sur youtube même l'autre
abruti avaient fait nul quoi jean toutu
quoi ouais c'est génial
mais le fait dans les calmes pour ce
match fable c'est fantastique
c'était le match qu'il fallait les
calmes grâce aux eyzies où et quand il
me donnait 5 % de chances de gain sur
tille à ce point comme ils ont été très
généreux on regarde sur f5 il peut lui
planter cavani g5 fantastique je vais te
mater comme une merde sécher j'abandonne
je n'en peux plus quoi bahia 6 2 après
une heure de match parfait leur premier
set d'appui bon voilà c'est juste
montrer star qui joue mais bientôt c'est
la réal pas nos coeurs s'adressant aux
jeux très dynamique et cleveland donte
whitner iata temps qu'un qui lui dit que
sow est en mode ghadir gousseïnov su
rester là mais il est dans une capitale
et lumière il est déprimé elle c'est ça
il ya de moins en moins de lumière à
l'écran en théorie fois l'hymne grosse
lumière un gros nez on derrière sa tête
il a le visage déconfit
cg bien sûr ils en furent mais
j'aimerais ce que tu cherches pas encore
va quand même changé le format du truc
l'année prochaine parce que ça quand
même ça ressemble quand même à torture
non mais tu veux faire quoi d'autre
carson aux tortues à tout le monde
banon mais ok mais qui fait 17 en trois
points quoi tuer les super 7 du tennis
quoi 3,3 points gagnants à 3 3 et un
départage bullet de départager tu fais
enfin auquel il ya deux sets zéro tu
fais un troisième set on dégage van est
et fait défoncer voilà tu as perdu 3 1 3
032 voilà un massacre fin 4-2 du coup
mais voilà le truc c'est que le mec fin
c'est de l'humiliation coiffard
n'est pas trop déçu toi demain là pour
la finale du masters qui va quand même
support bon match et même pas su par
deux ans atteint du bon dieu a raison je
sais pas poule 6 en fait c'est une des
raisons pour que tu saches le trou
profond c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles j'ai pas mis goffin en fait
aujourd'hui
non mais ça me faisait chier d'être
contre toi en fait le temps après des
groupes assez d'argent non mais je
pensais que j'allais perdre de toute
façon mieux que je n'ai pas trop envie
nan mais j'aime pas trop quoi parce que
du coup j'étais pas fait parce que
j'étais enfin quand j'ai vu le premier
set j'étais super content lui tient fait
demain il va non mais j'étais heureux
pour toi tu as ce que je veux dire
et après les premiers soldats resteront
bas c'était juste normal et d'acoustique
et fier nul
[Musique]
tobin qui dit mme bientôt magnus va
claquer la grotte pour finir ce
psychologiquement serait fantastique qui
claque une robe on adore vol ouais t'as
roll sauve allait porter plainte pour
humiliation publique sans doute très
inconfortable quoi et comment ils
appellent ça le hashtag dénonce-t-on
port ou je sais pas quoi et je dénonce
magnus carlsen et c'est le cers carbone
non mais ok mais il va le prendre dans
toutes les positions alors heureusement
mon avis c'est bout on assiste à une
exécution
je passe à la théorie que ce truc là
pour à moitié on peut traiter rue
non mais ok prochain mais en fait je
sais pas trop non en fait la position de
sault et puis après il se fait défoncer
oui mais à un moment tu vois enfin il
fait des conneries en vain une h 10
trucs
juste le temps d'aller chercher du 5
minutes quoi donc de faire des gaffes la
secal perdu pas mal de poids sur gaffe
je dois penser 4 ça va sa position et
faire de ce match un nom après j'y serai
pas lâcher quoi ya pas de raison de
perdre cette partie dans le vent non
mais en fait le problème je pense c'est
la proche psychologique mais maxime il
en avait parlé que le truc c'est que
magnus il a un impact psychologique sur
les autres et si en plus il fait un coup
comme dam des six mois je suis sûr que
d'amd 6,5 ou qui coûte cher dans le
match en fait même pas pour le coup en
lui-même est tout à l'heure ce qu'ils
ont vu hockey même saut à une attaque
sur enfin il valait une attaque plus
rapide dans un ruck opposé il va les
changer les dames et en fait juste le
message psychologique envoyé cgper alors
que magnus le seul truc qui sait pas
faire dixit vlad c'est défendre son roi
en fait il a dit que c'est le seul point
faible de manu c'est qu'il a du mal
quand il doit défendre son rang c'est le
seul moyen de le battre en fait ces
attaques est sombre et il le sait en
plus et donc situe quant à l occasion
d'attaquer son voiture refuse de le
faire mais tu le mets dans un fauteuil
quoi enfin le mec tu ne touches pas son
seul point faible c'est comme si je sais
pas accuser qu'un mec un nouveau revers
et une joue jamais son revers times sur
les vertus vous même le coup droit passe
exactement ça en fait et j'en remets ça
phycologique envoyé à la deuxième partie
enfin c'est grave quoi c'est comme sur
rugby tu refuse de prendre une mêlée tu
vois surtout panel effet tu ne peux pas
quoi tu es obligé de faim tu prends
mêlée parce que tu veux montrer que
voilà quoi tu es là quoi donc y avait un
démêlé je vais te défoncer mais du coup
ils se foutent de notre gueule
on vient de me lasser même pas évident
peut-être pour socopa trop sortir ton
food for thought vais changer qu'il
existe à redire c'est simple je bouffe
faux bécasse je te fais à trois médecins
font montre indécis sur échec
donc tu as eu tort de deux buts de fer
g5
c'est pas ça sent pas bon pas du goût de
très mal que je pense franck qui dit
bout il a peur de la mêlée non mais
c'est c'est un problème parce qu'en fait
le mec son seul point faible c'est ça
donc si con tu peux toucher son point
faible
une fois tu refuses mais c'est mais le
message que tu envoies c'est tellement
négatif sur des matchs sinon c'est
important la psychologie je dis pas
qu'il gagnerait le match ou quoi mais
tant le voit pas des messages aussi
négatif je ne m'attaquerai pas à quoi au
contraire il faut le défoncer toute
façon contre gries tous avec une autre
histoire ghetto valdes vers l'attaqué
tout a enfin versé vlad qui va le coach
est quoi c'est je t'attaque tout en quoi
un maintien qui les premiers fils d'un
prince tu te fais défoncer quoi il se
fait défoncer ok tu apprends à 5 tours
dire mais j'arrive un bon ok ou dame f6
même peut-être et tour d un et je me
lasse tour des huit mater je te défonce
quoi lance alors que leur centre banon
mais fallait agir par la cia rien qui va
mais on doit peut-être pas trop le choix
c'est une position mais c'est pas ça et
le choix au palais juste pour dire tu
tues tu te fais défoncer en 5 + 2 déjà
déjà l'hiver +56 gagne ça la part
d'hommes c6 et j'espère ex 3 2 et 5
change les doors combat il ne se fait
pas en effet j'ai trois mois je regarde
les dingues pour jouer attaquons temps
au prochain match c'est mardi soir donc
c'est dans trois jours et ce sera magnus
contre blad non mais enfin quelque part
pas un wlan mag envoyé en éclaireur il
m'avait dit hier joue contre lui je
pense que c'est un adversaire un peu
fort quoi tente le quoi bon du coup il a
vu qu'elle pas assez fort quoi il envoie
un deuxième de ces dogues great you quoi
tient test lui quoi bon bah sigrid super
malade à dire bon bah y'a plus que moi
que banon j'envoie femme coiffant femme
va te battre contre lui quoi vous faire
quoi bon voilà vlad
bon ben ok j'y vais quoi bomber à vlad
regagne 0 les mecs
vlad en fait c'est superman dans marvel
le thème des bandes et les autres autour
de cet espace vous et qui fait je peux
ça marche est trop mais ça marche c'est
peut-être
c'est pas de la psychologie de comptoir
je suis trop vieux pour courir ccsa
existe un truc là ce donjon enfin parler
le bric le fait que tu dois jouer damas
inquiétudes remettre le mec en danger et
si tu met pas en danger le mec se sont
trop bien en fait surtout dans un match
où tout fonctionne les parties comme ça
c'est très important
superman dc oui excusez moi d'ailleurs
justice league
pas si mal en ce box un film de super
héros comme un méchant tu es gentil mais
il va se faire mater jean sirois 1,8 à
tour des huit matches sur wyeth claudia
même s'il est hors de cet abandon ap la
gestion d'un déficit avait-on j'essaie
tout
mais il conseille son b3 ou ce qui
marche pas du tout sur mon bureau
face à ces machines en effet une rue
jusqu'au bout enfin fais nous plaisir en
moins c'est une grave bond de 5,1 comme
garde est 5e en effet arrive cinq après
mes choix de garder les récents
championnats du monde juniors c'était
lequel 81 ou 79 g plus contraints de
taille un jeu pour fouiller dans mes
livres ça tout de suite
ce livre là nous citer la partie que ce
à quoi ces noms en culture de fabien les
minf si la tension
je sens les limons attention à toi ça je
fais des cas se fait partout b5 des 5
j'ai vu ça c'est à dire que je ne
connais pas encore je connais mais je ne
sais pas trop donc ce que je bientôt par
le tas bruno senna qui brubru accès là
parlons qui veut dire aussi quand il a
joué la montre aussi ce n'était pas très
bon psychologiquement serré qu'il
envoyait des dessins des messages très
négative quand même c'est pas bon dans
des matchs sinon à demain une nouvelle
joute contre radjabov la couleur bon
alors je pense donc une petite nul même
c'est bien joué je pense razzia avec les
mares en fait parce que le mec va pas
tenter que tu fais une une et il reprend
les blancs sommes en fait faut qu'ils
jouent tous les mecs vont et puis
calment ils tentent l'idée d'un bateau
je pense vous faire + 3 dans le tournoi
voilà plus de déjà c'est pas mal plus
trop envie et objectif focus 2 s'est
déjà taillé est belle chance
les trois plus trois c'est sûr
j'y crois à fond femmes on n'y croit pas
là on y croira jamais non
tu peux peut-être faire f 5 noms des
cinq aussi j'avais proposé les deux donc
je deviens de partout et prend au sein
qui prend 2,4 et il va mettre le
cavalier en russie ce qui va couvrir des
cases importante et un bris cavaliers
j'ai 5 km à 10 h trois têtes genre la
dame qui arrive sur la diagonale le
cahier qui commença sera menée sur les
cases blanches façon fantastique en plus
qu'à écouter c'est tu sais pas quoi
contador au total 2 par toulouse on est
sur tous les fronts sur tous les azimuts
redoux champion du monde juniors du coup
peut-être comprend des trois échecs
intermédiare dame de france est certes
après tournez pas je tourne les pages où
je ne trouve pas non mais ça c'est
ségali à rien même les blancs qui sont
sensiblement mieux meilleure structure
de pions laissé lundi tous les noms
attention votre os 5 blocs et fab sais
rien non mais c'est peut-être même les
blancs qui peuvent y sont pas moi aussi
si tu es certain de prendre quatre voilà
on y arrive je me dis monde juniors
défensive a fait retour des deux et il
va mettre la tour en a deux et c'est
finir et malhonnête c'est parti entre
tamponné et gary en 1981 tamponnais et
froch et 6 g 3g 6 b3g s'est trouvé deux
c5 ces quatre des six coups g2e 5 voilà
ok c'est si ce que ces trois des trois
quilles 8 intéressons l'arrière franck
ils demandent ce que je pense de
l'analyse automatique un cottage en
parlant des bus de retransmission c'est
parce que comme on veut élargir un peu
public des gens qui peuvent suivre les
échecs bas le truc à côté ça permet
entre guillemets aux gens qui se
connaissent à peine les règles de
pouvoir avoir une espèce évaluation en
temps réel après deux nuls
de toute façon
l'ordinateur n'est pas très fort et donc
fabu même moi d'ailleurs
on comprend mieux la position que leur
dis donc c'est juste un petit titre
indicatif ça permet de voir si à une
gaffe ou un truc comme ça et puis ça
permet de présenter aussi la nouvelle
fonctionnalité de chat ce point comme
quand analystes est parti mais là ok
sauce ils jouent ça c'est mauvais
psychologiquement mais joue pour ça je
suis invaincu ce jour la montre
l'allemagne où tu vas pas faire ça c'est
pas dans la mentalité dans le ciel pas
très vikings n'ont laissé 4 bat c'est
mieux de nous écrouler
mais ça on va monter un peu mais c'est
en fait sa bonne réputation pour les
blancs on retient bahmani avait déjà
battu gold pro che sling là-dessus
souvient mais très vite d'air enfin tous
un peu bizarre à 3 des rockets mais en
fait il est pas si mal ce que le centre
n'est pas ouvert on va entendre dire le
fou mais florence 2 ramené la tour
achalandé un lycéen va se lancer un est
juste royales far est ce que vous en
avez rockets fonction carlsbad anneaux
dans le sens dont 3,2 j'imagine
en fait ce qu'on va faire quoi que ce
soit je veux cette variante bah en fait
elle est pas si mauvaise non plus une
obsession la maison que sous ne prend
pas du tout de mettre sous sa robe baby
rompre crack magnus le prend encore
moins sans perdre le foot est bon magnus
au moins il va nous manquer mais là ça
ils te mène 8-3 et c'est tout quoi mais
il joue pas tout le temps l'ouverture
qui marchent pas quoi ces paquets f3b
trois chats chrono en anglais n'ont pas
une et en répétant les pétards ap tempe
et sol si vous ne passez près pas et
qu'on passe au sérieux bain bafé toits
défoncé et la stocke un autre à dire
c'est encore 10 minutes de 5 + 2 je
mettrai le chrono pour la prochaine
justin et les petits soucis d'internet
au début là c'est fini maintenant ça va
gt gt inactif pendant une heure j'étais
déconnecte automatiquement
natif cake avec hassen quoi cette fille
du carlsbad mais le truc c'est que je
vous prends il veut faire foi je cet
échec à vallée prend h4 et houphouët
vincent collet se barre avec son fou
mais ami laurent h7 maintenant il va
sûrement lui faire du gca tâche car tu
sais pas je le sens bien même si on
s'attaque à la dame je vois bien faire
une attaque tout sur tous les azimuts
quoi bon faut quand même pas que l'autre
avec tron ses cadres le fondateur
qualité de la lésion devais me faire
chris hill qui est des 600 mètres le
cahier noir arrivent à se replacer un
nombre intéressant mais le problème
c'est qu'après il va te faire bessin
qu'il va mettre le calme est lancé
quatre plus tard peut-être doux
[Musique]
ok qui est le centre beaucoup lu et
saint claude j tu tape un peu le cul
bref c'est tu contrôles des cases moi
j'ai trois pour commencer wainwright qui
veut cacher leurs anges et démons
produit déjà bombardé norkom s'est passé
ok il a obtenu le pion passé aylagas c4
et mary kay je pense que faire passer de
g4 en fait tourache un g4 g5 en fait non
mais s'ils ont su aller le maté en fait
mary qui y bon tirage pourrait plutôt
les noirs avancent pression
tel temps pensé 4 au fil de qualité et
carieuse 5 ha mais attend peut-être d'un
match trois chefs commencer par moi j'ai
deux sur la b 56
mais du coup à sa guise ou puni chars je
sens qu'elle va être bien du deux
épisodes je suis assez content var dès
ce soir après le match je pense mais il
va lui passer tout reprend ses quatre
cavaliers 5 je pense à en donner ok mais
quand même on est mal pas normalement ça
devrait gagner celle-là je suppose que
donne la jauge d'évaluation je fais un
léger avantage noir mais n'est pas très
forte cette jauge profondeur 18 oui et
je regrette ce jeune que les jeunes je
devrais plus mais peut-être que c'est
moi qui ne suis pas avisé mais je pense
qu'ils aient tenté de messages je
pensais aussi vous vous protégez faire
dame f5 et comme ça tu va attaquer le
pion des cinq passagers tu plantes rapt
et du tour prend du cavalier 5 et ou
alors pour avoir le score en direct
c'est à côté du nom des joueurs tu peux
le voir pour dire à ceux avance assez
confortable pour magnus pour l'instant
mais tu as à fouiller cette dame f5
il a peut-être la tour prends un
cavalier 5 après j'ai pas à les
récupérer c'est qu'à taper a qu'à taper
tout en fait le guet juste qu'on passe
un temps fou 17 à la moitié ont fermé
vous donc émergents cavaliers 5 pouces
et 8 vous très bien je vous aime
vraiment son artificier à l'eau gaza
peut passer peu date 9 mb 8 où je suis
pas le porte n'avait peut-être qu'avait
lieu saint caprais sur dame b vite je
veux pas manquer cette même mer issus
fekkai épreuves sur qualité c'est bon
bah je vous ce bar moi je sais pas trop
mais bon la meilleure du caillou cinq
tours c'est ici c'est ok mais sauf
hockey a fléchi soit enfin je comprends
pas pour combler 5e pas jouer après 5
secondes que ma tête c'est le bon coup
mais je sais pas à pas et 30 secondes ma
vision à 3000 date à pans de bois c'est
tellement large qu'il a lieu cinq
quoi c'est pas dû l'être humain kiev qui
prend dix élèves sur l'année tout pavin
fabu - en fait on prend des élèves de
temps en temps quand on a des places bon
allez faut aller je vais t'envoyer le
lien sur le site vidéo et chaque point
comme j'imagine
ouais mais attends gens voient l'avenir
valeco avec toi et puis si sur la même
page et quoiqu'à pas voilà donc vous
nous écrire toute façon en fait qu'on
nous garder nos vidéos sur youtube donc
depuis stream
souvent on vous dit oui il allait bien
en dessous machin il ya là-bas simaga
les trucs tout soit pour les stages ça
pour les master classes soit vapeur des
cours
si jamais même dans un club et que vous
le des cours collectifs que de vous
faire sa distance au programme et enfin
il ya plein de trucs possibles donc en
fait on est on est on est complètement
joignable n'hésitez pas quoi ben voilà
c'est ce que j'ai montré avec les
flèches pendant que tu disais ça qui
allait avoir fou des trois fois ci
dessous des 3 la tour prend g6 bouillon
prends ça marche aussi mais mon tour
france c'est plus classe plus plus beau
plus beaux masques et la sueur dame
prendre les coups il va non mais je
pense que je souhaite vraiment pas dans
le match c'est pas possible de planter
comme ça injuste et le chou qui le fou
qu'on tourne comme sa dauphine au camp
avec 2,30 à la pendule enfin je
comprends pas en faites pas je pense
cela en saut qui s'en fichent plus mince
et pas qu'en version ps qui joue c'est
pas possible
non mais l'allemagne où ce feu ne fait
pas cinq minutes regarde du foot mais
bon il il prend les geckos sérieux
non mais ok mais ça abusé enfin joueurs
c'est un massacre
mais les médecins se doutait mais un
massacre au niveau du score mais là
c'est un massacre aussi au niveau des
partis quoi lui des partis en quinze
coups kwassa louis n'a pas repris la
pièce la nuit des trucs pour le moment
mais quasiment six ans qu'on parlait
hier est utilisé plus neuf ça m'avait
l'air beaucoup pour pour magnus est en
fête
enfin s'il prend le truc sérieusement ça
glisse à 6 mai un peu l'accélérateur et
tout se finira +15 plus voir en fait ce
match ouais ça dépend à quel point il a
envie de le terrasser le mec que je
reconnais que vous avez notre monde
s'est tu et gagner bons termes et ajuste
impunis isolé pour rien ouais mais bon
je pense que c'est vraiment moi bien
peut-être un full méca âgées d'au moins
25 balles tu fais d'amd de yacoub les
cas tu te fais cloud et tu fait qu'ils
doivent à leurs noms mais enfin non
bloqué mais on a assisté à une exécution
heureusement que je sors pas les
punchline du rc parce que j'en ai plein
des punchline songer à pas mal et rap
contenders et la sueur sauge pour en
sortir plein
j'ai plein de trucs qui me vient en tête
la tête du sbk et des cinq noms jeunesse
cavalière qui a poussé un ok mais tout
est un coup en fait un an qu'il est
redoutable et tu veux faire refouler
cinq prochains marguet gps d'attac forte
des blancs et puis tu vas juste pilonné
le roi et des cat km exigerait retour eu
un bref le roi entouré mais je veux
foulée ça mais c'est ça mais c'est se
moquer mais chacun sait que les clients
enfin justice manet moquer mais sachez
envie de te dire ils seraient moins
ridicule avec la grotte
non mais là je rigole même plus non
bloqué mais tout est bon quoi mesdames
h5
je gardais d'un jeu
je vais dire match 5 pouces et 6 g4g 4
ok la finale il va là il va tu m'as tu
aurais ça fait un an qu'elle pousse
pousse et ça il faut cette fois f6 je
viens tu attaques et plus avec le foot
mais l'autre foncé si ces grands
mangeurs sont sortis les dragons de
komodo sont partout enfin j'en peux plus
quoi faire chaque fois que ce qu'on
regarde y'a aucun nom mais ok mais c'est
déjà les quarts de finale il ya une
fugue un match intéressant du truc
coiffage suis vraiment désolé les mecs
par un quelque part tu as à me même mais
moi ça me ça me met mal à l'aise par
rapport au tonton du bled qui regardent
le truc ils disent facture ils disent
qu'ils avaient fab 20 expliquez-moi
cette merde
bah c'est ça hein mais on vous a pas
vendu de rêve avant vous a dit que ce
serait sûrement un massacre mais là
quand même c'est mais une trop grosse
différence de niveau ne sait pas assez
mais c'est vraiment comme federer dans
les premiers tours de grand chelem en
fait un fin ouais mais bon le truc c'est
qu'en face c'est comme si tu avais un
match fait d'avoir une gorge gérable
c'est pas 6-0 6-1 6-1 quoi perdre le
match d'ailleurs en général tu les
gagnes mais bon au pire mais que
province est de cette race ajoute la ce
et boucherie sur douche ou non mais
c'est pour free c'est que des boucheries
cette année j'ai joué je vais écrire à
rennes je vais soumettre julie soumet de
changer de format biztree n'est pas
content jarvis rien te dis non non mais
bâle ou non mais j'adore ces matches
mais juste je sais pas soit faut mettre
des mecs moins fort au début et que peu
un petit gamin tours de qualifs et je
sais pas manu ces machins et hikaru il
arrive en demi-finale en fait un premier
tournoi pour arriver en demi finale du
truc on te les bosque fouta les boss qui
arrive boss d'abord aux cardiaques
hinault sylvie des idées plutôt bon sens
votre karachi je suis pas convaincu y va
par contre car ou non mais pour moi car
yakine hikaru jeu mais car yakine favori
des rejouer les mecs et je le dirai dans
la vidéo de présentation je me fais je
vais me mouiller je vous mets car yakine
vainqueur et great choc car en scène ce
sera pas la même
mais quand même à nous non mais je te
garantis que ce sera chaud je mets ok je
sais que c'est un charlot on avait
compté
mais je sais que ça me met gringue
rempli de seule question c'est juste
moins fort voilà après il peut sur un
match non mais tu viens non mais je sais
qu'il va être motivé
ok il va avoir un plan de jeu machin
mais bon non mais c'est pas lui que je
vais enfin l'écriture laborantins des
gains pour longtemps non mais ok mais
vlady là tout un tas de plan de jeu
contre magnus en fait non mais je sais
que le match sera pris très très très
très au sérieux et il y a que deux mecs
qui peuvent battre magnus d'après moi en
match en blitz c'est carrie akin ben
détrompe toi
détrompe toi pour moi il ya que deux
mecs qui ont une chance je te dis pas
qu'il est favori je te dis qu'il a une
chance
tous les autres ce sera un massacre
hikaru compris des rondins de l'an
dernier non mais hikaru aucune chance en
fait le s'il ne va pas et rien ne va
mais les deux seuls qui ont une
microscopique chance c'est gris tchouk
et gary green pour défendre des
positions où sont venus en finale
mais qu'arrive ndiaye trucks qui est
champion du monde de billes disons qu'il
est une autre aura quoi enfin il a tenu
au magic mike championnat du monde il a
aucun problème psychologique contre lui
mais aucun face à roscoff et le truc
c'est que great choc se considère pas
moins fort non plus il seconde ne sert
pas moins fort en bis que magnus
il dit juste que le problème c'est le
bullet en faites pas je sais enfin j'ai
parlé à vlad il m'a expliqué il m'est
l'unique problème c'est le bullet mais
sinon en blitz je considère pas magnus
plus méritants preuve de bons battant
preuve d'autant de gueule menace à tous
ces soins que cinq ans de bouffe le truc
contre ses pions on a gagné c'est le
pogramme respirait déjà vu dans le
dernier match sur mac est non mais c'est
fatiguant de se prendre des tactiques en
daim socoa pas le dire mais moi je vois
ça en commentant en parlant de trucs
avec toi à côté quoi a juste chez pas
voir votre banane et cela prend à chaque
partie c'est une honte
non mais sérieux au point je combats à
partir jusqu'à calello tu prends des
cours mois jusqu'à 2100 toi jusqu'à 2000
50 moi je ressens un beauf annoncé
vouloir sais pas je peux dire très
piètre l'ordinateur dont arriver
davantage noirs cassis décisif là dès le
premier coup saluant pl à sa position
d'échec 970 - 2,03 et noir se tua le
trait ça te donne un avantage ces quatre
gars la veille évaluation quoi le mec
non plus hein tu joues en deuxième
quelque part l'autre te donne une
adresse mac do steinitz règles style
listes d'électeurs situation de ses 5
points d'interrogation le jeu un beau
champion de deux cases manif je vais
plutôt de reese tous les jeux quoi bon
j'ai ciblé six bombes et trois de plus
voir ces traces de pièces soit chic et
voilà je pense que sow tu lui as mais le
corps d'une chaise on est mal les mecs
ne faudrait pas que ce que les manières
d'être en pls devant l'écran le pauvre
l'invoquer là il ya trois sets zéro tu
as pris 3,1 3,3 tu dégages par la fin on
arrête ta souffrance mais là c'est
vraiment le manu c'est dragon de komodo
coiffe à versailles et a mordu il te
garde 3h30 quoi est fait de la charpie
la ffhg la caméra de faire comme lui qui
te mordre dans tous les sens et tu
retournes claque
alors il a décidé de ne pas analyser
cette partie comprend plus rien y
comprendre il le peut dire que déjà
c'est dire que ça existe à ce jeu qui
aimait à se prendre 4g carette d'un
match complètement fou la tension et
magnus qui a les blancs le parti veut
faire gaffe sylvain qui vont croire et
un match entre komodo un humain mais
quasiment non mais quasiment plus bas
qu'ailleurs ce sens qu'il est très
intéressant mais moi j'ai deux sets 3
way
la preuve on voit tant pis oui mais je
te gère avec karelia l'a déjà fait en
trois huit
on dirait un match à l'image des humains
contre les ordinations
qu'est-ce que stekelenburg van contre
commence la partie on t'enlève deux
pions du centre dont tu t'attendais noir
tu as peu ça tape à 17
bon ba kobio gagne quand même des
marques en même temps un franc qui écrit
l'humain voit les enfilades non au la
punchline de de franck non mais ok mais
je sais pas trop quoi vous dire face et
quand même tout match quoi enfin je sais
pas
le candide je pars il ya 20 minutes je
reviens 10,3 jared cela et stoppe la
violence non mais enfin je comprend
enfin enfin restait quand même enfin
rester pour nous quoi voilà enfin au
moins nous rigole ce que je pense pas
que sur les autres chaînes je pense
qu'ils sont très sérieuses et doivent
analyser ou alors on ne comprend pas
quoi et comment voter sauf deux matches
comme ça alors c'est un animal c'est
c'est le meilleur joueur je n'ai jamais
vu jouer mais on oublie tous les
articles moi ça m'énerve à dire tous
connaissaient bien les mecs
suivent la mode du moment une comtesse
qui passionnera mondial avon carlson
c'est fini quand même quoi s'ils sont
l'avenir bombe à venir narguer c'est
comme quoi tu te parler de dhimmi
travaux t il sera également là il en
2001 mais j'arrive à détrôner federer
oui ballotté par les mecs à 37 ans il te
défonces encore bon allez il a perdu ce
qui se rapproche de mode ou je sais pas
quoi mais c'est pareil sauf quand le mec
are you on al'impression nouveau
kasparov banon surtout pas du tout pas
du tout être le nouveau petrosyan si tu
veux mais c'était hallucinant on peut
les mecs les commentaires de merde que
je vise les articles non mais là ils se
disent mais même en échec 960 ont fait
se fait masser stratégiquement dans
toutes les positions ouais les mecs pas
moqué n'ai pas trouvé que carlson en
face fox non mais la garçonne ce carson
il faut il faut respecter
non mais attends les parties qu'il a
perdue car le sun c'est quand il
regardait la télé quoi là elle a regardé
lula d'arrêter de regarder à la télé
bien les maîtres 6-0 qu'enfin jarry le
match en fait il veut aussi donner parce
que dans huit minutes il ya le début du
derby madrilène donc bassin en faites
pas on peut s'attendre à pouvoir revenir
un peu repris après les rencontres après
québec effet petit rock l'ordinateur il
siffle ça y est comme ça ça je ne
comprends pas ce qui se passe
pal csaky kering n'a pas le téléphone de
la gamme de téléphones de sow pour les
conseillers la grave dans mais je pense
qu'ils devraient faire une robe en fait
c'était pour se lâcher quoi ça détend
une fois vos réveils chaque jour jambes
très bon pour la santé
tu sais ce que je fais pour ne jamais
prendre de grubb je la joue moi même
[Rires]
tous les matins
moi je suis sûr de perdre en prendre
autant de domaines linguistique est
parti oui dans les jockeys mais juste la
fin malgré ça on l'a enterré aussi la
faillite tournoi je sais pas comment
machin mais bon ok peut-être
bref ça surprend autres processus donc
le problème 5g pro905 forcé et je sais
pas je ne fais qu'appliquer des cinq
trains jours gf qui est des cinq dans
des détails n'importe quoi edf qui a été
cinq séjours alors puisque sur dalle
premiers riffs 6 ouais mais rien qui
protège les six qui défend son point bas
non mais ok peut-être perdu enregistré
qu on peut zoomer en quoi les thèmes de
la master class d'hier ne rejoue ce très
bon bah a joué un coup vous retrouve à
quatre ou cinq noms mais en fait
vraiment dire combien il ya quatre mecs
6 à 4,5 mètres sur une autre galaxie
c'est maxime quand même il en fait
partie great choix aronian hockey qui a
pas sur internet parce que machin mais
ok magnus hikaru écart yakine en fait à
5,6 mais qui sont juste au dessus du lot
et m'hamed peut-être mais genre les
autres ne peuvent pas ne pas jouer non
non il n'a pas joué mais géré par la ce
et les mecs qui peuvent rivaliser en
beach quoi notre à son nom mais le mec
ne va pas se faire défoncer comme saf
agir tatata peut-être si cette mecque
dans là sur la planète qui peuvent jouer
contre magnus
ok normalement ils vont perdre mais ça
va pas être de la charpie lassé de la
charpie
leurs pions prend et qui a aidé 5
attendent le truc ces trois là bas c'est
celui en garde d'un bon sac d'abord
pensé si son vote ouais donc tu peux tu
peux t'en [ __ ] moi tu m ils font plus
attention prendre part à ces impressions
prend aussi ce que je ne prends pas tes
pièces gérard je regarde la chaîne
bitstream très très souvent et je suis
au courant quoi tu as une maquette au
courant elle s'est dit michael hill sans
l'esprit en fait je pense que c'est il
ya une semaine j'ai découvert la chaîne
vitry bon après avoir joué contre eux
ils se disent enfin je suis dans
l'esprit maintenant attention attendu 67
face aux tensions et des messages en le
chat il dit que à temps mais je peux
déjà des trucs de lui qui avait lieu
vient pas d'un mach 5 en fait pour aller
vraiment à la barbe à dammaj cinq bouts
bon en fait que de cette chute est sûre
ce mot reparle très vite j'ai oublié
vlad une éval en fait les dents une
clique c'est la ligue 2 ce qui met des
raclées à ce que j'ai cités justice lit
quoi car non ce n'est pas la justice
league car le sel gris chuken vn et
toute la clique face à vlad le superman
et qui joue un simultanées contre kiel
et défonce et la hoguette à batman qui
vient il faut se débarrasser de ceux là
de quoi il devient trop puissant trop
dangereux
quoi ahmed hammache 100 gagne enfin pas
je suis complètement fan du coup je sais
que j'aime bien aussi
on aime tous top truck t de cette idée
bref cette quel point ces six bons pour
madame se fait fourchette en début de
jeu prendre le train b sat franchini
vlad c2d alors 12 et s'est fait défoncer
par vlad franck pour que tu saches ou
même bon et il a levé 5
dommage c'est déjà très bien sans
options qui seront au final tu attaques
tu vas faire qui rallie à 4 qui a essayé
5 on veut plus quoi une vraie charpy
totale quoi non en fait nous on est on
est les connards dans les matchs dans
les trucs de gladiateurs quoi tu le
faisais pas tant est-ce qu'on le sauve
non le tueur lethu américaine mais c'est
efficace je te prendrais tu reprends
aussi simple que racaille preuve la
bombe a visé abandonne sa sphère 11,3 +8
normes ok mais s'ils veulent y mettre 20
28 ont ils eu mettra quoi fin on se
croirait à france all blacks ce ça me
rappelle france all blacks ce match mais
attends je vais te dire ce qu'avaient
dit les ordis pas le logiciel
ils sont très loin du compte en fait le
logiciel de simulation
qu'est ce qu'il raconte est il juste
neuf noms mais au total mais faites sur
le 5 pouces de merveillie +2 ouais il
émit un truc de mer n'a pas été très
loin du compte
c'est un an quand même + 4 et les
pronostics et 7,3 pour magnus
non moi je suis dit faut bombarder les
bons seront 3 3 et les trouver le sort
de ce tournoi
non en fait tu essayais pas il m'a dit
que je sors aussi idéal était très
stupide de jolies cibles du régime
beaucoup plus en fait je trouvais qu'ils
jouaient beaucoup trouvent et on est pas
pour ma le joueur juste voiture fait
léviter mal que ça là les choses que je
jouais mal de toute façon ça ne serait
pas à changer tu vois ça je pense que
c'était s'était pas en option quoi je
n'y avais pas l'option bien joué je
pense bon ben ok traduire ça l'air
méchant ce qu'on dit mais c'est sûr que
de nombreux membres passent carrément
mais quelqu'un a intérêt d'être
passionnant
comment c'est possible et c'est plus
toutes les bottes banane possible je
sais pas
peut être qu'il faudrait faire un site
le vlad fact un peu comme le chuck
norris facts serait une bonne idée ça il
est déjà tout de suite convoqué mais non
mais je pense que reggie doit arriver et
faire ok stop
enfin je ne pourrais tu juste tournoi tu
as perdu
non mais même pour l'éternité on ne plus
devoir elle serait pareil pour ceux qui
regardent les raconte ender comme moi
que manu 6/10 times genre il à être son
clash quoi j'aurai le défoncer ok mais
on ce tracé trop quoi clémentine n'a
invoqué le mv al green shoe que c'était
chaud quand même c'est un match
intéressant glisse tout cas tout cela
est à + 3 + 4 mai évoqué mais il était
maximum à +5
ouais et puis ça revenait plus 3 + r je
ne pouvais pas dire c'était fini on a
espéré en bullet tout ça qui remonte
mais là ok y'a pas faim il ya eu match
même vers la grille tout à une match là
il ya pas match mitch et vos deux qui
dit kevin a les meilleurs résultats que
wes l'esu contre magnus carlsen non mais
ok mais enfin j'ai reçus y
enfin je sais pas quoi enfin c'est trop
là où alors il aura le droit
d'abandonner le match mais aussi
éventuellement ben brik scouts doit y
avoir une case reach oui tu es tu clique
dessus un énorme est ok parce que c'est
trop massacre en quoi
à
mais tata coco avec un ris et foc un
joueur de classe mondiale comme sow se
prennent une pareille dérouiller non
mais en fait il ya une différence de
classe c'est ce qu'on a fait par votre
dépôt et carrières inc
et le blick se montre la classe tout
juste que les parties longues public se
montre le talent en plus parce que en
fait en partie longue
ok tu as le temps de nous glisser quoi
face à l'iss l'écart de niveau quoi tu
as tu as plus de temps de réflexion
c'est moi le talent brut quoi ce look et
une petit à petit tu comprends est ok tu
arrives à mai mais n'en faites juste là
non mais c'est ça c'est que tu vois que
le talent brut s'effacer cosmique mais
juste à montre la cosmic cité de
carcassonne ce qu'en fait sous il
écraserait la plupart des joueurs de la
planète en fait maintenant l'heure des
grands maîtres serait complète n'importe
quel grand maître à 2007 ce serait juste
écrasé par ouest gso et la quarantaine
il écrase ce mec là c'est juste pour
montrer qu'il ya des galaxies qu un
malus doivent être données avant
d'envoyer le match entre entre entre
entre nebo et écart yakine quoi la miss
hallucinant alors avec une de granma sa
crypte
bah oui mais bon qu'est kraken été
champion du monde de pizza indien ses
marques et hyper doué ouais mais bon ça
c'est du vent être à 13 ans les mecs qui
a eu à faire ça en fait ok c'est juste
quelque chose car ce n'est pas forcément
dans un grand soir auquel on disait la
même chose dans le match contre donné
pour contre carrer à qui on est toujours
la même chose que les mecs se font des
fonctions ils sont parents des grands
soirs moi je pense juste que c'est les
autres sont tellement fort en face qui
te font mettre dans un mauvais soir en
fait peut-être que minc était très
heureux avant son match contre brive
jamais que l'on va fouetter la
tranquille ou chez lui bon
il sentait très très bien donc magnus ne
passait du monde qu'il est nul non mais
je dis ça de manière péjorative mais
c'est sa fin c'est tu es bien jusqu'à ce
qu'un mec t'as juste plus fort que toi
dans la bafin agences comme si federer
demain il va avec beaucoup plus fort que
lui qui arrivait à y aller avec joue
très bien il y aura un mec qui le ferait
passer pour un idiot en fait face et ça
a toujours été ça dans tous les sports
j'imagine au tennis qui n'est pas
federer nadal murray et djokovic depuis
dix ans barrette à tout un tas de mecs
qui nous paraissent pas si fort que ça
qui aurait gagné des grands chelems
pas jo bahreïn jo-wilfried tsonga aurait
gagné un grand chelem alors que là il
passe pour un mec hyper nul quand ils
jouent contre federer ou contre nadal ou
quoi mais en fait il passe pour un nul
que contre 3 à 4 mètres dans la planète
en fait voilà c'est pas il faut il est
juste super forme et ben magnus est
tellement un monstre qu'il passe pour un
gamin c'est tout will deal et rennes
s'étaient fait juste défoncé par
carrassan aussi à quelques jours mais
j'avais jet lag mais dans nos zones de
800 rispal jet lag en fait s'agir
semaine une session du jazz c'est juste
qu'il fait défoncer c'est enfin c'est
pas la vallée tu peux dire un jet lag
pour te rassurer pour dire que t'es pas
que t'es pas en sueur mais en fait tu en
sueur tu te fais des photos mais malgré
ça aurait rêvé jusqu'en chine certaines
score ou peut-être au pied perdra
bientôt peut-être que vingt dix matches
n'avaient comme tennis féminin du stade
là bas c'est ça tu enlèves serena et
venus williams bat à plein de filles qui
vint tout d'un coup de sang qui sont
beaucoup plus fortes
c'est enfin apte à des mecs ça peut être
humain rogers sur terre battue que sont
nadal et les râteliers les 5-6 roland
oui il a fait tellement de finale et là
tu le voyais face à nadal en finale à
roland il n'arrive plus quoi alors que
le mec juste démonter tout le monde
était finie chaque année que oui mais
déclaré nadal en face qui prenait 1,7 il
était heureux ça le faisait passer pour
un mec super nul ils pouvaient pas
renvoyer un service et rappelle en dix
jours la 11éme est ok mais renvoie son
service qu'en fait c'est pas possible
le mec qu'a pas le meilleur circuit il
foutait tous les retours revers dans le
filet dès le deuxième set face est
horrible
la pire chose c'était la finale 2008
soit c'était 6-1 6-3 6-0 limites à
tendance l'arrière comme ça c'est à
vomir quoi bon quant à internet sans que
le mec s'est pas jouée à fait banale
d'un jour et aux caisses des sabots ne
pas être sa surface entre guillemets bon
déjà de la gagner une fois et il a fait
ils étaient 4 s'incline en grand chelem
quatre ou cinq fois de suite
en fait tu as c'est exactement ce que je
disais le truc d'attaqué droit parce que
tu te rappelles le seul mec qui est
battu à la loyale on va dire ça on est
sûr sans rien nadal à roland garros et
soderling en fait et le mec avait un
style complètement différent des autres
en fait d'attaquer mais en fait c'est ça
c'est que magnus fin vlad manie de la
seule chance pour le battre c'est ça en
fait sinon tu te veut tous les tous les
joueurs du monde se font défoncer ta
seule chance est d'attaqué en fait j'ai
dû ou s'il a refusé d'attaquer enfin il
a il a eu une balle d'attac il a refusé
et s'est finie en fait un jeu de mots
cheap de robert claing centre basse et
ça c'est que les mecs fou il a une balle
courte me diouf je te renvoie une balle
en cloche quoi les gages
bon coup cette partie mais bon juste
l'ouverture de magnus et quand même pas
ouf
après ok ce qui va conversion là mais ça
donne quoi cette finale 2 1 kg va cet
argent tu peux rendre le pion avec 5 j
ai fait faire bref quatre bombes ont
fait ou pas tu fais reprise prise avait
tant besoin
mais si mais si je mets le pion à
justice je te ferai plus on prend et je
ferai roi ici si tu mets peut-être que
je ne mets là de toute façon il a mal
placé ses pions parce qu'ils laissent
deux coups d'attentats magnus mais là tu
as été un succès avec les blancs tutu
peut la perdre je te fais h6 ok mais au
pire on va perdre et après on sait juste
qu'on dit non parce que je vais te faire
à 6 et j'en aurai un deuxième avec 1,5
de plus d'attentes tu vas perdre et
c'est tu vas te reprendre 0 f de redon
non mais tu peux finir on appris hier ok
mais les deux coudes attentes
ok si tu bouges et le curage celui-là
perdre et c'est sûr en gardant le pion à
vieux du goût et tu peux faire bref de
rois de et j'ai pas accès à g iii mais
ok peut-être que je peux te faire h 5 h
au pôle plant h4 g4 juste à tête de sow
tu me fais besoins en paix être à temps
et si je te faut un pion sur age 3 bah
je vois la retraite mon attention
après je te fais jr huawei va faire bref
2g garde je te prends c'est que c'est
mon rêve de toute façon on va les deux
pays plongé aujourd'hui est qu'on peut
perdre si apple pion à deux je viens bon
ben on redoute à son talk show
je peux te zoug alors disent pas par
part en part en cacahuète mais je sais
pas il est nul c'est finalement 3,3
roitg trois rois des trois-rois jusqu'à
3 c3 roi h5 roye b de droit âgé 63.2 h4
à prendre dès 3 h 5
on va devoir rendre un peu de social
deux hommes auraient ensuite dames et
bien dab et parlons d'autre chose que
l'ordinateur des moins six mais je sais
pas si c'est ce qu'ils disent qu'ils
veulent d'autres on va voir d'autres
langues vous faisait qu'attendre
non ok mais il va bouffer à 7 ou pas au
modèle peut retomber 3 reprendre alors
on peut pas gagner du temps en temps à 4
à 5
je vais faire assez ingrate et thierry
bourdin and away
on voit bombe est simple les stadiers
complètement débile manier mais 0-0
alors tu peux rien calculé vraiment
débile non ce mardi comprend vraiment
rien de thiais 00 ou non mais il est pas
capable de calcul final de la mission
contre dame c'est impossible
pas assez fort bah il donne son avis
quoi ouais c'est forcément un avantage
mais les têtes que juste le temps sort
pas été juste échec tout le temps mes
bras c'est un endroit meilleur
mb ça nous donne des 200 matches
ouais ok 17 70 ans attendait d'eux mais
je crois que tu prends ces cinq en fait
tu prends à cet essai 5 bat depuis pour
tout vol ok mais il a failli gagner
cette finale de pions un quasi
permanente à cape town - et donc tu vois
je dors dit tu me disais c'est quoi non
mais j'ai clairement donné il a juste
parti l'a mis il commence à mettre moins
six au caire comprenait rien comprendre
à la finale il était incapable soir si
ténu joue pas et à un moment donné quand
il est parti à l'oeil droit en fait il
m'est témoin 6 avant donc je sais pas
peut-être y avait un truc à faire
peut-être fallait jouer à 5 avant
peut-être fallait faire à 6 à 5 jeux la
main avec le pion à 5 pouvoir faire un 4
qui on prend des 3 b 2 b 1 dames en fait
qu'à ce que je veux dire parce qu'en
fait tu cites avait introduit le pion à
saintes avait un temps de plus leurs
études année en premier chose
mais sauver la série s'il a bien remis
sa caméra la monitrice et l'ordre le
soir ouais enfin le sourire c'est vite
dit mais il a retrouvé des couleurs
ils disent que quand il a été la
question je parle pour l'année sur le
live démarre n'hésitez pas à partager
une nouvelle fois il faut partager
toujours tout le temps je vais mettre le
chronomètre
elle me sens bien maintenant on sort
quand la leçon chez ce buzz et femmes tu
vas me dvd la maladie chez pas et aussi
de faire fin d'année l'estonienne n'a
pas eu aussi un truc sont vraiment
accéléré mais qui sortira plus tard on
ne sait pas trop quand mes donc
possiblement planer toi ça m mais les
masterclasses se situe voire d'y vivre
ouais bon ça c'est autre chose mais
master class qui ont fait grève deux
fois par mois si ça t'intéresse tuque
lancé sur le site open c'est la fin du
mois le 29 le vertueux tu peux les voir
en replay il y aura un live spécial est
bonne il 28 ouais ça va notez bien la
date 28 ont fait un live bas juste team
du stream port
y'a pas de raison plus comme ça donne
envie bah il y aura peut-être les 7000
abonnés ainsi se chauffent sûr sur
youtube parce qu on y est presque 7000
ouais ok me va c'est pas à la base sont
proposés le truc c'était pas pour fêter
cette pile ou des 10000 ou des 6000 ou
pas parfait c'est juste à le dvd des
master class gleeden bike tour n'est pas
prévue ou là mais bon ok pas chez
bateaux dont on pourra commercialiser sa
peut penser compliqué on pourrait mais
oui
mais met donc la sed parti qu'est ce qui
se passe les et chérif bah explique de
partout big n est pas bien tu fais du
tout j'ai trois tunisiens qui étaient de
moins l'espère t pieuvre compense la
compenser parce que le roi et des
roquettes à un pion en plus pour la
calabre est ok tu vas juste sur ces
quatre très vite l'histoire bien bien
souligné le roi au centre bonjour avec
les blancs à choisir port de calais 8
chez pas 5 h souper diop ou mac il veut
s'en prendre le fou qui s'en prend au
camas ça ok on a eu cinq le juge avait
proposé sa langue et doit combiner pour
sow je pars en va-t-il jouer la même
vitesse concert cuiseaux sauf que là du
coup ok sur 7 c'est pas parce qu'il fait
trop calé je crois que tu es en place
avec le cahier des sites
que tu dois peut-être tenté un repas
dans le jardin match 4 cavaliers sekkat
échec s'est joué sur la découverte ou
quoi mais ça n'a pas marché qui commence
tout cas les c4 qui on prend un tour d
un baril va faire la même chose dans
l'autre sens et après jouer sur une
découverte qui doit pas trop existait là
bas mon avis ils vont n'importe quel
quotidien la dame sait si seulement
juste toi c'est moi je viens par madame
ont accueilli tout modèle mais donne
ceci cela bon ben ok c'est l'histoire
qui a mené ma tombe et à me ranger cette
dame de 5
et c'est marrant l'ordi avaient pensé
que le soc a revu en trois puissent de
prévision de l'ordi ces cinq cas
probables et son entreprise de pensée
sera plus seul en pointe use alors dit
c'est tout mais c'est horrible un les
algorithmes et ils savent tout cas assez
généreux pour quelles raisons
peut-être parce qu'il veut toujours
aussi hésitant cinq puissantes chez papa
ils doivent savoir si lord il savait que
le coup d'envoi du match real atletico
sera donnée à ce moment là mais attend
de voir sur la caméra il regarde ce
qu'ont fait diminuer le chrono n'est
plus la caméra mais peut-être qu'il a
commencé à regarder le match je dis ça
peut expliquer la baisse de régime
alors le 28 c'est un mardi s'attendre
mardi note notre live plus ou moins mais
plus ou moins dix-sept mille attends je
vais le dire combien d'abonnés
maintenant en direct
bats toi qui se bat c'est youtube qui
c'est bon je ne sais pas que je ne sais
rien ok on a estimé à 8 183 117 6 7
on dit ou tu fais quoi non mais c'est
plus que faisable en fait surtout si on
en parle sur douze cantons veulent à une
vidéo la semaine prochaine quand on en
reparlera on peut dire oui vous aussi
vous comprendre normalement au pire on y
arrivera le jour du live au 7 mai du
coup sa fille l'abonné c'est pas mal
mais les 10000 ce sera épique tout on
veut diminuer leur coût très important
vers plusieurs égards déjà on aura de
nouveau accès au youtube space ils ont
changé avant c'était 8000 abonnés mais
on sait dix mille trente ans en juillet
un chiffre très important
bon c'est rond non mais on y sera dans
un an et quelques mois une grosse soirée
nantes je pense qu'on fera une soirée
douce soirée live mon pote ouais je
pense aux fera un live de folie tête un
lagon mais les têtes on fera un live
live pas de bol on se rend dans un bar
une soir à paris on est tous là mais on
peut faire ça ouais on fera sa dernière
très vite stream qui partout partout
tout le temps
info avoir recopié avant pour être prêt
non mais là on fait ce qu'on veut faire
c'est de nouveau structure carlsbad
essaye de faire le plan qui avait trois
cas et c'est ça qui est très productif
généralement et en fait quand le mec te
fais ça bizarrement normalement faut
jouer avec le 5e tour ça qui prend des
airs de qui laisse pas faire magnus mais
aussi on sent quand même un retour de
ceux-là fab les uns des autres ils l'ont
il faut s'en font parler faire contre l
algorithme maladie
on se trouve on fait des matches de ce
pitch est virtuel comme ils ont dû faire
avec belle équipe capable en kmh un nom
mais j'imagine qu'ils ont défendu une
moyenne comme ça fantastique fantastic
je n'ai pas pu y assister tiens pas mal
le sacrifice de qualité pour un rabat
non je pense que tu ne prends pas en
fait il n'a pas pris oui voilà trois ans
que le pont du casse du cheval est ce
que ce sera car il ya quatre ans prises
derrière
catering aussi de faire 24 heures 24
heures de blitz mondiale et 10000 en
direct ça tu l'a déjà fait en plus j'ai
deux affaires on pourrait se relayer ça
pourrait être marrant on regagnerait
encore mille abonnés pendant le truc et
j'en serai complètement fou tu penses à
baho bien on peut faire ça alors
l'occasion une fois on est ensemble
ja en février non mais pour les 2000
pour les 10000 pour les 10me drame et on
peut le faire pour le faire ça oui mais
pour les 10000 en fait juste
je pense c'est bien une fois un vrai
vêtements en live mais bon ok on en fait
des énormes aldric les stages et
compagnie pas d'ailleurs à ok les dates
on a commencé à définir les dates quoi
si vous voulez commence à cocher sur vos
calepins on pensait faire 9 16 juin et
un autre stage septembre comme on sait
pas trop ce sens quand ça commence à
être très palpable non là normalement la
finale quand même qualité de plus il va
la mettre après j'aurais bien aimé faire
tomber s'ils s'aventurent b5 à son
amoureux hockey seront pas seuls
je crois tout b6 et que les blancs du
coup le monde c'est de la merde tu as tu
ça je sais pas mais tu as déjà aidé
biologique est en fait il vieillit ses
juges visuellement ce que je raconte un
jeune harry calculer mais tombé cinq
arrivées tournée
mckesson normalement gamme en a manqué
ses qualités de plus non mais imagine
position avec pure b5 b6 sais pas si
t'as pas de colonne s'appela de f3 pain
et du boulot peut être ça gagnait mais
annonce un joker gagnant mais papa le
gaipes ou encore pourquoi le ferme
ok le truc c'est que le roi va venir en
trois versions tu pourras rien faire
avec des pions ce que kiev si c'était tu
peux tenter remarques 5 f4 et tout est
poussé comme un mal et le baptême et
c'est ce qui va tenter en fait
ok tu as souffert trois des quatre cinq
rois c5 faut monter je pense limiter les
mottes
ouais mais ces choses qui veut te faire
tourcoing f de faire courir le pion de
l'autre côté et toi j'ai vu juste dans
le bain mais celle place suis pas sûr
que c'était simple simple à n'importe
quel moment fait mais là c'est pas
gagnante aura deux retenir la casa 8
non mais déjà comment tu te débarrasses
du problème peuvent être faits retour
des deux tours tour c'est de tout le
temps peut-être même far-west 5
ok on tout le monde ces trois coups pour
ces deux tours bouge bien et je pense
que ce qu'il veut faire c'est que si tu
vas faire pour preuve de tourcoing h2 il
voulait essayer de faire tour 17 à 7
sacrifier la tour ouais n'y voit que de
faire d'ailleurs ouais mais bon tu te
fais tourner des scènes peuvent choquer
mais c'est l'idée tour des trois en fait
c'est surtout reprend des cinq
maintenant il ya trois des cinq échecs
et il a le temps de revenir se sacrifier
en fait il est ok quand même soit on
prend des sang et or pendant son procès
quatre tours des 8,3 b3 long mais on est
de fait c'est un homme prend tous ravis
à huit mois oui mais après tu pourras
g53 g4 et va chercher le contre mais du
coup le pouvons
je donne tout pour s'éviter une tour
sitôt reprend ses deux battants pin
histoire entourant oui mais tu reprends
des 5
je reviens vite
bon arrêtons contre joël roy h et 5 h
sans qu'un truc mais en fait c'est
souvent ce qui est fantastique dans
cette partie de la part de magnus on
sait pas s'il va gagner perdre ou quoi
mais c'est qui peut même la gagner
maintenant face à d'autres perdent en
main et au hockey juste tu compliquer la
vie de la terre son nom de chats [ __ ]
je choque qui me saute dessus 1 est très
content mais c'est hyper chaud ou froid
eu 5 est maintenant enfin tu te sens et
que dans les tours c'est 5 2% de sauge
et puis on prend et d'am-dam et adamu
qui déchiraient du gouda 500 gagne il a
vu
non mais tu vas te faire ça mais on re
3,5 ou non enfin retrouve le roi des six
blocs est pas mal le gamin ouais moi
sous une petite route la dette
faut arrêter de regarder le real quand
ma mère fait pas la même variante à
marquer mais simpliste a pas super super
réputation mais juge je comprends pas
qu'on dirait qu'ici je veux qu'un truc 1
puisque déjà au can des cadets 3
jeunesse et parce que nous on va 10 et
faire d'autres choses auxquelles truc
c'est qu'il est très bien préparé je
parle a dit que c'est un des joueurs les
mieux préparés au monde association et
que en fait quand il n'a pas assez
préparés qui vous passez près pas sa
mini me son niveau quand même aussi du
coup monsieur sa chaire en martinique
nom sera quelque part en europe mais en
martinique ont pour eux comportant un
truc un jour en faire des jeux par la
vigilance est bon
d'ailleurs je m'en viens refaire le
tournoi s'il a lieu cette année on verra
donc et je pense les mecs si à un moment
où on peut partager sur les réseaux
sociaux le truc c'est maintenant quoi
comme ça les gens qui viennent il croit
que le match un peu plus eric prévu
parce que j'ai peur que carl scène ils
reprennent la marche en avant est là du
coup plus 6 autour ce chouchou c'est
chaud en fait ouais wesley so c'est pas
gagné goussé enough rougeurs mayer s'est
pas gijon
peut-être fou c4 rwc à deux tours hk
tourache un vrai faux ans et 4,15 pour
attaquer des six places à nouveau très
agréable pour une cession s'élève à la
guinée parce que tu as dit que des
cibles un peu à droite à gauche
non il ya déjà un essai de l'afrique du
sud commence bien se dire n'importe quoi
la france oui j'en ai marre que fut
possible et je pense qu'il faut tirer
qui reprenne mon entraîneur quand on
fait alors la méga quoi alors là les
petits peut-être d'un pro b cette dame
des cinq ans fait tout ouvrage 5 me fin
mais ça c'est une horreur ce position
majorité dans le premier set et d'amener
5 pour passer devant et entrée de
partout 5.5 très bien
[Musique]
non mais c'est pas sérieux les
ouvertures de ouèssè mais peut-être fou
g8 la and on marchait pas à tour
problème c'est qu'il y aura pas match
était-il fois foulé cette note les
processeurs fait recette
ouais enfin voir ça
cela le ch ne ronronne pas trop fort il
est là j'ai eu le temps de me frotter un
chat essais deux par le mur auront
renault micro tient très heureux je
connais mon micro dessus a dit très
content il est fait il ne me lasse plus
quand je ne peux plus bouger il est là
et on sait pourquoi il est venu comme ça
je ne connais pas ce chat s'y tient
fabien les visages ce qui commence le
match très intéressant comme commentaire
j'aime beaucoup je suis abonné à la
chaîne bitstream onze de base je vais
aller voir un peu ce qui se passe
homeaway cela il se démène pas
finalement une solution qui avait l'air
un peu compliqué il a trouvé un truc
comment gigoter quoi norman est ce qu'on
est sûr qu'on regarde vraiment le vrai
match man u so i qu'on regarde pas des
algorithmes c'est les ordis qui font les
simulations du match quand on ne sait
plus maintenant
mais est on sûr qu'on est dans la
réalité nous mettons pas dans un monde
virtuel de base mais je ne sais plus en
fait mais je crois que certes mais qui
est sorti un article mais j'aurais
peut-être grosses chances qu'on soit
déjà dans un an deux versions il dit oui
en fait pas de bon sens et moins d'une
chance sur deux quand même et que 30% tu
vas et tu expliques a passé un petit
truc de sémantique quoi mais ce qu'ils
qualifient un monde virtuel c'est quoi
macha méril actuelle date a fait quand
même très attention à ce que tu lis
femmes à la santé mentale au même site
virtuel je vis ma vie comme je la vis
par personne chargée
oui enfin on s'en fout mais le mec fait
des articles à il se fait du fric sur
notre dos pour éclairer ce dont on se
fout complètement oui c'est une réalité
virtuelle et alors ça change sociaux
sont donc tu dégages ta théorie
n'intéresse personne rend nous l'argent
que tu as obtenu pour un voleur quoi les
mecs se fait insulter au final c'était
horrible m'intéresse pas l'armée c'est
très possible
normal que matrix en fait soit pas un
film de science fiction du tout en fait
non matrix ce film très réaliste c'est
la réalité seuls films réels en photo
tout le reste ne sont que science
fiction tous les films d'amour ça
n'existe pas ce n'est pas ce qu'est ce
que tu fais tu t'y bouquet de roses non
tutu dans une bulle conseil dans les
tuyaux en fonte une pile enfantine puis
n'existe pas seuls ceux qui jouent la
grotte sont sont réels sont real se sont
réveillés quoi ils ont accès au vrai
monde n'avait par morpheus i mania qui
en fait matrix est un documentaire
nature radiographies pour l'atrix très
intéressante même si tu vois comment tu
es né tu comprends si tu veux comprendre
je voulais grob
je suis issu de lapin sinon on continue
à jouer quatre décades la 1984 oui on
connaît quand même
george orwell way up très important
mais c'est pas pareil cette question de
réalité virtuelle j'adore la réponse de
groucha seulement d'une dans un monde
virtuel on ne sait pas c'est fantastique
ça nous appelle je ne me prononce pas
sur cette question génère je n'ai pas
aimé photo ans arrivait en toute
objectivité je ne dirai rien bon ben on
attend quoi qu'il en soit très sombre
mais on fait ce qu'on peut
comme quelques exceptions j'ai mal est
fait je comprends pas ils voulaient
peut-être faire tous rêvent de il n'a
pas vu qu'il est ou refi quatre échecs
contre échec qui te laisse pas rentrer
sur la deuxième sur un tronc f2 mais là
ok tours 2 enfin même pas enfin je sais
pas faire n'importe quoi pour un 4-3-3
ok comme ça j'ai tour de revenir et
mayotte félicite pour magre qui est
manuel est très content dans le chatt
voilà voilà
francky une réalité quand il commet ne
repart pas dans les échecs pas parler
d'échec quantique c'est ma j'ai même pas
compris l'objectif du jeu en fait on va
le truc tu ne sais jamais où sont les
pièces jour 50 % à en vivre assez débile
en fait si tu ne sais rien quatre tours
fc est très attention à toi qena est
bien pour 1,4 13,5 et la finale de pions
gagne ou pas mais bon dans mango soient
tentés de penser qu'elles viennent mais
c'est pas sûr en fait il va peut-être
pouvoir mettre le pion à cinq essais nul
en fait non mais même sur l'a4 en fait
juste avec quatre chocs l'option blanc
sur un maillot sauvetage atteindrait les
gens qui ont fait le choix ils doivent
savoir ya quatre décennies voir pourquoi
ne pas gagner alors on en reviendra vers
le bon concept mais avec quelques uns
cattacin que c'était nul non récurrents
la classe de laisser l'eau de ferracap
le chat dès 6h et c'est ma souris
d'ordinateur pas dessus mais j'ai
toujours cette finale il très dissipée à
tout d'un coup lui a compris la finale
était nul suffisait ils regardent la
télé nouveau en fait oui c'est ce qui
explique en fait le regain de forme de
wes né sait que magnus regarde le real
madrid et manchester -leader êtes assez
pour la fantasy league
et maintenant maintenant regardons rien
mais attention la mi temps approche donc
bon temps je vais sortir sous chape
cette pièce là mais j'étais si fier de
martyrise c'est fantastique j'ai ouvert
quand même sur une virama le résumé du
match de rugby en même temps tu
m'entends plus réalisé j'ai quand même
eu vers rugbyrama pour amorcer le match
de rugby en texte c'est fantastique au
premier truc que je lis du q1 se rate
sous une chandelle sud africaine non
mais je pense mais la seule équipe au
monde qui est incapable de refaire une
réception de chandelle patje sur voirie
l'équipe de france sur voit la balle en
hauteur ils sont incapables d'en laisser
tourner le truc quoi s'est déchaînée en
fait mais techniquement je me sentis
très faibles donc des blacks c'est pas
déjà reçu une balle en hauteur
que faire je ne sais pas quoi donc oui à
tout pour elle sa 35ème donc c'est soit
dix minutes de répit il veut c'est de
remercier maintenant pas s'il va revenir
mais maintenant ça passait mais bon
c'est sa chance après c'est la mi temps
ça va piquer mais peut-être qu'il ya
deuxième mi-temps pendant le bullet et
qui à faire une remontée à 2 août non
j'étais nativement une
je ne peux plus suivre
je suis cuit les arrières en fait le mec
et arrière en puissance et spécialité
c'est justement la réception des
chandelles en fait de base c'est le truc
qu'il est censé savoir faire ma il a du
mal je te parle pas des autres 14 génie
de l'équipe
non mais c'est horrible
non mais ça me ça me fait mal de voir
cette équipe de france sombre et fab
j'ai plus de commentaires sur le chemin
de la tranchée mais très sympa mais bon
il ne peut plus payer pas tout à fait
sascha déjà exclu quand il veut non ça
on en concède mais lui vraiment quoique
ça y vient faire un truc line on dégage
il revient tu leur mets par terre et
reviens tard il s'en fout quoi il ya pas
de nuit ça lui fait rien c'est bon il ya
d'autres chats tu vois des frais dans
mon mari bon bah nul voila mais pourquoi
il essaye pas bas mais je crois il a une
colonne ouverte s'il a un peu mieux et
il essaye pas afin d'affecter karo kann
[Musique]
ok merci ça m'énerve c'est tout le temps
la même ouverture en fin de journée mais
qu'il faudra interdire ça pourrait faire
comme le championnat du monde là des
ordinateurs le tcs et goethe oblige à
jouer deux premiers coups hasard en fait
fawaz art dans une prise dans une base
de données en fait et tu ne peux pas
refuser de jouer de l'univers turf hier
par un vaincu tous un peu aux quatre un
peu des quatre avec et noir et un peu de
duke est figé 6b si l'une des quatre des
cinq wagons hilal tarin kwhot non il est
monomaniaque et amanda j'ai eu
l'occasion ces parties seraient la même
position mais je ne sais pas
[Musique]
tour 3 tours h3 tous fous et 4 9 4 il va
jouer la montre six points de retard
moi je regarde du shoot turon p2
découvrons un très très beau temps la mi
temps j'étais défense je me fais je le
fais chier 3g 2 tour à tour h 1 c'est
moi qui vais prendre mais d'autres
personnes que il est un peu déjà une
oreille de coupe et on la perd 0,4 pour
le sens tu l'annoncé votre choix
le nasdaq prend des cinq ou six puits
ont réussi ces clous et c'est ce que nos
qualités c'est que j'ai trois filles à
l'étranger 3 mai
bah tu n'as rien la casa jeu est
contrôlé par le cavalier aller au camp
rock et il va t'attaquer leroy attaques
et les projets de tourisme de la mort
qui tue et échangent suffrages et du
tour à chaud je t'échange et gina et
magnus on sent qu'il joue plus vite tous
les autres partis des 30 secondes a
répondu la côte est et un arrêt de jeu
non ils regardent encore la télé
serrières éduquer plus vite c'est très
très très long quand même aux autres
partis
leur attaque nuit en fait un outil de
wes esso et aniche sommet en fait en
fait toute fin j'en ai marre que tout le
monde s'en prennent à anish giri en fait
je viens tout pousser un coup de gueule
de faire une vidéo coup de gueule arrêté
fait un saut est beaucoup moins
entreprenant zoologie jouer agressif
c'est juste c'est pas qu'on doit faire
c'est parti mais faut arrêter de dire
que guy est jamais gagnant quoi ils
jouent pour attaquer justice n'arrive
pas à conclure au quai c'est comme un
joueur de tennis qui attaquent mais il
s'est pas posé une volée ok ça arrive
des apparats mais le mec il essaye quoi
mes sauts de ses épaules basses à la
sauce basse et les espagnols à l'ancien
l'écho des à l'ancienne les coastal eco
ridge à et tout cinq verres à sotigui
mme brou guérin bah oui mais mais mais
girinon enfin guéri c'est pas la même
chose sur les mecs ne s'est pas conclure
il sait pas concluants mais arrêter quoi
cette attention à yorick à idées si
c'est chez ricoh fo chatrier j'adore le
carrière j'ai trois dans cette partie
très intéressante
non mais guérit n'essaie jamais contre
u15 scène va s'y coller des bonnes
positions contre 47,1 qui avait séduit
enfin qui a un beau score positif contre
40 cède aujourd'hui un haut niveau enfin
en plus il a un peu taquiné dans les
conférences de presse et tout quoi nous
tue trop chaud le nom mais en fait
enfin j'en ai marre de se guérit bashing
en fait ça m'a énervé en fait mais juste
et pas du tout objectif chose que je
veux dire c'est juste des malades
comment ça à dire ça il a fait beaucoup
de lui dans un tournoi et tout le monde
continue à répéter ça tu as comme si
c'était vrai ok il fait des nuls mais
bon c'est quand même su regarder un
match de foot l'équipe fait 15 tirs
elles marquent pas un but et 17 équipes
n'attaque pas bah non c'est juste qu'ils
n'ont pas de buteurs coiffe à ces
différentes mesures ce que je veux dire
ben tu peux attaquer faire comme arsenal
arsenal il attaquait tout le temps il
marque et jamais un mec ne marquait pas
trop vu que même par rapport à l'
attaque qui faisait le football total
qui faisaient parce qu'il n'est pas de
buteur et c'est pareil sauf guy ritchie
dire sauce est différent ce rythme est
dit mais quand défense il attend lots
dont le corps n'a cessé et
grèce 2004 sous gk rester à son équipe
de jouer de mettre une tête n'a émaillé
j'ai jamais dit que guité excitant mais
enfin guéri il essaye coiffe info faut
arrêter farès et les mecs vous êtes vous
ne regardez pas les parties de geri fin
c'est possible ce genre de maximy la
barre il a essayé de maxime et de jeu un
truc là bas ils rentrent dans les neiges
d'orphée to fire c'est pas la première
fois qu'il monte à un nageur contre
maxime j'ai reçu un coup bas il fallut
désolé qu'on fait le mec fédéral fin les
mecs fait des trucs ça sur moi pour
isoler certaines qualités maintenant
banon mais il s'est tu pendant cinq mois
true north zina non franchement le dire
ils n'attaquent pas bah enfin vous ne
regardez pas les mêmes effets que man
même les candidats il a fait que des
nues il avait raté quelques positions
gagnantes d'ailleurs sur l'île en chine
et ligne là où il a eu cette réputation
en fait il avait quelques qu'elle fut
gagnant là c'est perdre en mode fait une
découverte qui est unique on dit tu vas
faire d'un français 8 la wii même mais
ok il y aura peut-être 4 qui en fait un
lieu en fin de parcours aux chambres
n'ont pas d'âme pensez vous peut-être
dante cinq échecs ou d'hommes se donne
six sept cavaliers quatre blocs et même
si je sais si c'est le troc et puces
non mais c'est pas un grand attaquant
guy et tout mais c'est juste que c'est
son défaut de style c'est pas conclure
les parties je pas en train de dire que
c'est un grand attaquant je comprends
juste pas pourquoi c'est lui qui a cette
réputation alors que ses sauts qui fait
ça tout le temps pas de chasser ça kim
et hu est en fait sauf si tu ne l'as pas
qu il va il ne va jamais si tu jamais
jamais jamais et il dirige la justice un
nom il arrive pas elle c'est différent
c'est ce que je vis comme une équipe de
foot qui essayent d'attaquer qui se
débrouille pas mal cadets bonne position
mais qui sait pas remarqué jarre même
cette partie d'entre eux avaient décalé
ashton qui existe dans l'arc lémanique
qui joue pour park où j'ai cinq machin
et qui forcent leur proposer et sais pas
ce qui fait une belle partie data quoi
ça c'est my new skies et ak steel points
d'avance qui peut déjà jouer la montre
est qui et qui joue pas c'est ça qu'on
veut dire ça le départ mais pour
l'américain host et soit dans son style
pasqua qui joue même vannes à toi et tu
trouves des cas les cadres qu'il prend
des cadres fait des trucs cool et là ils
reviennent à huile et md5 et chaque date
en rejetant des arts un chat mais dont
qui joue très bien qu'ils voulaient
disent que ce n'est pas un attaquant aux
caisses avec ce n'est pas un attaquant
les citez moi un autre mec qui rentre à
chaque fois dans la nasse dorff les
ventes hyper compliqué contre maxime
farago niveau enfin justice à aucun
grand attaquant haut niveau citez moi un
joueur qui attaque plus ok vous allez me
dire mamediarov ou quoi mais enfin je
sais pas mais ces deux trois joueurs
c'est 2,3 mais ouais t'as carbonneau
questions générales batak à renata
m'amène mais en fait guéri il est même
pas dans le lot des plus solides en fait
si tu réfléchis car jacking c'est pas un
grand attaquant du tout saumon n'en
parlons pas mon cramique ok il a un peu
changé de synergies mais oui mais il a
nourri russie mais a gardé des jeunes
aussi l'été comme time et après une
période où c'est plus du tout ça fait
juste techniquement ont été trop propre
il veut vraiment ils avaient raison que
je sens sont parfois bâti il a très bien
fait évoluer son style tout le temps
qu'ils ont amené qui s'est adapté à son
âge de sa force à se faire plus jeune il
est hyper agressifs ils attaquent à fond
après il s'est mis à hyper bien jouer
les partis qui avaient froissé 4 donc
les mecs savais pas trop comment
répondre après il s'est bien adapté à
l'arrivée de l'ordi dont des prépas de
ouf
il a toujours été là mêmes
les plus vieux quand ils jouent des
parties techniques longue en fait il a
plus de mal à convertir les petits
avantages ils apprennent donc du coup il
fait de la bid scribble ont commencé par
this will be blood encore la position
doit marquer mais c'est incomparable
mais j'ai avoir maigri n'est pas à
classer dans les joueurs les plus les
plus solides en milieu du circuit
d'ailleurs il a gagné la première partie
des grands prix d'air oui le grand
manitou jeu pour bien hydrater dachstein
chanson sur le petit peu juste mais
karzaï est en train de se marrer méchant
ça fait marrer que l'autre essaye de
faire annuler le même à moins 5 ans ça
doit le faire lucides
paris lui ça devrait être sot qui a
cette réputation est pas du tout guéri
en fait c'est dans les sauts aucune
testostérone dans son jeu à mes acquis à
top niveau et j'en ai personnellement à
part car yakine
non mais s'offusque le pire non mais
c'est en soi un haut niveau c'est le
seul qui ait autant comme ça en fait les
autres ils essayent plus qu'à une époque
à bâle
non mais ok mon karl s'allier ici
toujours blanc noir ils sont fous la
toujours jeune julien un revenir en bas
ok bon candidat et noir situe finul très
nul mais quand il ya des blancs il a
toujours essayé
maxime et c'est toujours un média mais
il joue à fond c'est un joueur car voilà
il joue bons mots d'assaut la cram nique
voilà vont attendre ok mais même nuit on
peut pas trop dit à paris kiev après bon
ça bouge et 50 en vain bon voila mais il
va pas sauter sur la nulle nakamura
bijoux inglee khamsa jours il est tout
ça joue les guerriers la dgid leur va
pas et c'est qu'on s'est un peu
vieillissant mais c'est pas le mec super
slim non plus enfin si on aurait par
exemple je pense que great show qu'il
est beaucoup plus solide que guy en fait
ils jouent beaucoup plus souvent pour
les nuls que guiry en tout cas jouer
beaucoup plus souvent à la botte de
karuïa kim yong-il bon jeu parce qu'on a
un devoir d y travailler juste 15e
mondial s'est pas mal pas mais
mais bon la banque entre eux via leur
total of pareil vieillissant mais lui
bah c'était pas du tout genre que pour
les nuls en italie et où radjabov c'est
un boost à kabila c'est solide ça alors
plus jeune des fois que toi que tu est
indienne c'est ma chance c'est autre
chose hélas d'ailleurs qu'on ne voyait
rouge était contente juste à 9h des
moments là je préfère compter quelques
jours pour les nuls mais pas maxime mais
juste ok il a fait une bonne action et
on va essayer d'y penser
ilitch aoudou solide non général ouais
non mais conclue dans les ovni fait mais
c'est vrai mais ok c'est plus une
question d'habitude c'est moins fort toi
pas tomber dans la non mais c'est plus
fort attention c'est la mi temps
donc je peux reprendre le large
paquet a eu 2 qui est français puisque
adam prend des deux j'aimerais trop voir
un math avec dame proche de tours h 50
il manque une tour sans codage et oui
quand on a le coeur de tout ça donne
envie qu'il envie d'avoir envie et ça
marche ça non mais oui c'est sûr de le
faire marcher en fait il y tournait sang
qui coule cavaliers en plus mais c'est
sûr qu'il a trop envie de faire bas me
senghor j'attaque mon cavalier très
intéressant boudin prend un jour
approche de tours h5 maratka
chinois qui était pénible c'était mon
goût et si la vraie mais bon tu puisses
lustrale cauchemar admirait même bout un
wayne en vélo c'était vraiment le rein
et l'autre c'était petrov sur petrov
avec les blancs des 4 6 4 3 tout le
temps à temps leur didonne m'attend 4
lors du trajet entre eux et j'ai trois
noms d'un préfet d'un problème de
cavaliers g3 et tour assiégée pour ça le
fait marrer très heureux mais ses
habitants je vous ai prévenus c'est
l'évidence dire ça prend 1,83 plus de ça
et là je crois qu'ils vont enchaîner
quelques unes comme fait on a compris
qu'en fait ils regardent le match de
foot les algorithmes était tout à fait
au courant
6 e troc et c6 flou 500 savoir 10 du
match compliqué
ok mais n'a pas pris investissements
dans l'autre il avait pris un jour dans
la trump offs qui s'abat que tout le
monde avait fait j'aurais fait mon père
ou un an plus tard
mais celui qui avait lancé la fin le
chinois qu'ils aient lancé l'attaqué
dans la sienne cannes c'était 7 et oui
je pense je les fais la vidéo contre
bruson action et bon de la de pouvoir
pourquoi on tue loup est un cauchemar
banon mais son style son style de jeu et
à rester invaincu pendant qu'on y perd
longtemps 90 partis voix mais bon à part
tellement il s'est mis à en perdre une
c'était la balance est une descendante
ou 2700 points
c'est choquant à lessines guinée s'ils
s'en soucier quand même beaucoup event
choquant mais voilà tout c'est l'âme mon
truc très beau joueur malheureusement ce
nra l'ont jamais laisser tranquille dans
sa carrière ella a même encore la coupe
du monde alors qu'ils étaient dans une
très très bonne forme il a fait une
super coupe du monde mais elle juste une
partie était pas là quand en rogne ans
parce qu'il a fait il a infléchi les
plombiers film l otan il veut des coûts
des mille îles à guérir au sens
développé par on comprend pas ses
marques avant il s'était jeté un génie
quoi ils s'étaient qualifiés et les
mêmes battus mur tu as quoi donc
forcément un génie quoi et à valoriser
une grande coupe du monde
limite tu veux je veux pas te d'ivoire
est bénie pelouse quoi est ok mais
c'était ce sont des fous de sa carrière
passée l'énarque ça enlève rien à son
talent c'est un des plus grands talents
qu'on est sûrs et cinq ans d'arrêt enfin
si en même temps l'histoire des échecs
mais qu'elle les nerfs ça contre mais ça
compte beaucoup d'ailleurs ces
différences de niveau intrinsèque c'est
la gestion des émotions de machin le
plein de choses c'est la première fois
que ce soit attaque et peut-être que ça
peut bien se passer
enfin je pense que c'est la stratégie de
match qu'il fallait qu'il y ait depuis
le début en fait ce qui est en train de
faire maintenant parce que eux qui
tentent f3 madame en jeu 3 3 5 points je
doive cinq mois mais c'est ce qu'il
fallait faire depuis le début du match
en fait enfin c'est la seule chance de
mettre à mal manu c'est de jouer comme
ça
derache trois mois je prends n'importe
quoi il ya le futur s'est vite ouais
ouais ouais c'est chaud notre juste part
d'impôts tu m'aimes g4 damas trois tours
f5 et too bad and magic mouse bungee
cadre d'un match en fait sur deux
soldats mais aussi ceux qui le défendent
mais encore mais bon david rajjou
repoussé huit en fait baver d'amd mais
aussi sous scellés bon bah du coup 35 de
la valeur et fonda ok mais je peux faire
peut-être ouais ok mais alors peut-être
un truc à l'ancienne genre fous ces huit
fois choix pour faire fois ci c'est bien
sûr évoqué vais faire demain quand même
fou à six et quatre meilleurs du foot
français
ouais ouais je pense que un mois c'est
qu'à damas ouais je souffle en aller
retour au x 6 x 6 donne des signes comme
pour le canon que tout soit donnée au
jour j si j'allais dire surgissant la
menace est là bas tous est forte on le
sait ça parce qu'en fait sur radio je
fais tour g4 et je vais te sacrifiant h
karaoké mairie va mater la saison ça ne
marche
non mais c'est le seul point faible de
magnus en fait ce dont on parlait depuis
tout à l'heure c'est le seul truc qui
s'est enfin pas faire c'est le seul truc
où il est moins magnus canfin et du coup
le de suivre ce plan de match il fait un
plan de match complètement stupide saut
donc il est fou c'est 8 maintenant je
pense
ou g5 même femme nous sommes en 2008 je
préfère parce que moi enfin vous avez
restaurant h4 et le fond ces huit l'idée
c'est de contrôler la case h3 en fait
d'un machin ok mais mais voir un truc se
met à toi on les a mal agi quatre prises
droit relate cette fois je crois
maintenant que l'algérie 4 ok fois
l'option prend qu autrefois du matériel
de soute détour d un très fort tour
prend b3 très bien je sais 4 ok
peut-être fou prend du coup pris ce prix
avec le pion et tu mets le pied en d2 et
au capital et besson pst en exemple qu'à
pousser des pions et a pu que ça à faire
aucune autre pièce nous fait marrer
c'est bon un peu plus jouer d'alger un
tabac mais ok on peut te faire peut-être
jamais belote contre plus de pions se
cachent trois étages et 2 reprend être
prorogée en amérique et mais je me bats
avec dom c2c comme une menace mais
regarde un match 4 je me laisse ta tour
à tour des six mois nous sommes des
trois tours je suis en tête dam des
trois échecs et tour des six premiers
mais tourner 6 7 4
mais vous êtes dam des trois échecs
comme moi je ne me prends pas je fais
tourner six mois je sais tu as pas
maladroite
l'idée c'était que yahvé damage trois
dames j'ai deux matches du premier tour
oui ok madame des trois noms d'autres
qui ont des quatre tours d ici la dame
eux deux quand même d'un pont des dames
preuve de roche 3 d'alger de roche 4g
5.5 d'un match trois matches d'une tour
g1
padam au pire il n'y a pas un père pète
à ok ça incroyable qui se la pète et ben
non le quai mais comment tu rates il se
marre car le cnc ou fils est mort de
rire à moutier mais comment tu rates ce
à quoi non mais alors quoi non mais
c'est tout c'est dingue tu as encore 40
secondes à la pendule tu rates ça mais
va juste faire il a l'air complètement
dingue devant son écran
mais déjà ça sentait pas bon quand il
sert à nez avec sa dame alors qu'il
pouvait juste attendre ramener le pion
h3 et je sais pas voir on croyait
vraiment l'équipe de france de rugby
à
ça craint bloqué au moins maintenant et
participants ont discuté c'est pas du
carnage
non
non mais ça craint quand même
nombre de l'asie on se croirait fasse un
tennisman français on se croirait face à
un tennisman français
enfin je sais pas comment expliquer un
tel raté femmes y avait eu ta pas une
explication à nous lâcher
non il est juste cru que c'était fini
il s'est relâché et boston d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui un autre grand événement
quoi c'est simone williams qui a loué un
château organise à thoiras blitz et
fêter son anniversaire il ya une
quarantaine cinquantaine de personnes
c'est open bar
c'est juste la soirée en angleterre
c'est sympa ça c'est un peu the place to
be qua non
regardez-vous sony gagne la section de 3
+ 2 du coup la pause et qui n'était pas
invité mais je pense et a invité fab
si tu avais envie d aller tu aurais pu
ouais non jeu face aux autres je peux
ajouter mon sac j'en parle à simone est
mort dit oui mais elles surviennent quoi
je pense à moins que les places soient
vraiment très limités et ma chambre
kanye west et va essayer de la gagner
celle-là avec le pion b c'est possible
mais en fait tu vois ces quads m18 bada
mais inquiets mais il prend perpète
tempo privé pabx et 4 je comprends rien
en fait
et elle a lancé sa ligne avait peut-être
d'un grand v 4 oui mais on va être
obligé de tenter vase de problème c'est
que tu es dans un match où tu es mené le
but on s'en fout pas que tu gardes ton
match de 50 points de 1.7 pas différence
car un match
du coup on allait on a les 960 la nulle
part qui en diront plus jusqu'au bout la
voiture reprend est parce que c'était
pas 960 bataclan il est fort son en but
laisse comparer avec magnus mais en fait
j'ai pas vu à la vitesse de la qualifie
je me dis que c'est peut-être un des
seuls joueurs qui sera pas avec les
cargos qui sera peut-être pas si si mal
en bullet je sais pas
normalement il ya un gros écart mais de
toute façon il va attaquer le truc sur
la mieux s'il ya une seule à il sera à
-5 fin était molle
non mais tout le temps mal sa vie est
mal dans mes choisi psychologiquement le
fait qu'ils tentent jamais aussi c'est
très mauvais message lancé un pendant
tout le match
en fermant après sa relance un micro
suspense s'il y avait plus 11 le mc
saïda finit là quelque part
mathématiquement ce n'est pas encore
fait
il était battu par erik hansen en bullet
with donc là ça veut tout dire sauf
carson a défoncé recruit c'est donc s'il
a perdu contre en scène kemayou
d'affaires b3 comment est-ce qu'il est
loin de rock et encore c'est trouver
trois baies de même mieux que son grand
retour bien nos grands crois bien
allez vous pouvez pas faire de t-rex ont
déjà bougé leur tour en fait
je sais pas ça avantage blanc la femme
tour sur la colonne ne l'avantagent
développement avantages des espaces non
ouais mais bon
donc m bouffer le pion et faisait quoi
mais je pourrais tu aimes les blancs
non mais j'y crois pas
on a un petit coup de pompe la femme je
suis champion sait plus quoi il ya nous
avons tout laissé
nous avons fait le tour de la question
ouimette de turn off the creation j'ai
envie de dire je regrette ce que ça a
dit sur facebook est ce que ça parle du
majeur est ce que vous avez partagé sur
facebook y avait but lettre qui démarre
c'est le moment de refaire le petit
partage qui fait plaise mais n'oubliez
pas surtout mardi un je répète mais
mardi mais même heure 19 heures même
endroit great shukarno scène oui et ça
sera pas la même chose
enfin de toute façon se rabougrit tout
cas font bros de vlad de partout on va
mettre des ombres de vlad partout ah
tiens ça vous pouvez casser joly tient
longtemps après il fout des trois échecs
découverte
mais oui donc donc sera pas joli gdc qui
demande des comptes de scor en fait t'as
le score autour des noms des joueurs
donc à 14 minutes et demie pour pour
magnus pour l'instant alors placé un
petit fou prend à 3 et découvertes
ouais je pas ou envie de le faire pour
le combo jeu pour les beaux jours la
beauté de l'est pour la beauté de la
découverte après ça marche parce marche
parmi le temps me le faire marcher ses
défauts
mauroy deux d'entre eux se cachent
moi on est ok a plus aucun avantage
blanc ce même peut-être les noirs sont
simples n'ont même pas les voir peu
campagnard son mieux mais personne
n'aime personne avec la tournée tu veux
te prendre du contre-feu je pense je
vais bien mais si cela perso pour faire
food etc à tour ces 8es machin quoi miam
miam un pour paraître j'ai pas afin
façon impression que sony ou même encore
maintenant pas faim il jamais jeu pour
gagner une partie qui a infligé un
paramètre pour faire flasher de fouet 5
ça c'est joli vert en mp3 oui mais bon
bref c'est faux et cinq tours f4 tout
reprend la foule cinq sets il posta
twilight 4 pour ce sens elle s'est
retrouvée cinq ans prend b2 quelques a
trop pierre bouquet va attaquer le pion
par derrière
même si ça doit aller dans la moquette
arrêtera le pion sur g7 au pire temps
fou est quand même très bien placé qui
est france à tours 2 tu récupères ton
pions et c'est nul on peut tout de suite
les trois tours j'ai trois tours g7 ok
pris 0,6 et adultes est content quand je
crois que oui cela n'a pas compris qu'on
va appuyer sur le bouton de kobe tout à
l'heure en fait ils acceptent jamais 2
nuls alors comment me rappelles tu lis
comme le salon que vous étiez n'a envie
ça fait pas à perdre de temps ça fait
rien fait de sa non parce que ça sent le
8e est pas content qu'ils briguent
dussault ah bon pas content de coiffer
par l'emea très déçu inflation qui finit
très déçu quoi c'est une fantastique
winery de charges car il lui faut encore
une news of change +1 ok il a l'air
d'être en pls s'aimer ok mais il a enfin
pourquoi tu en paies laisse enfin là
c'est plutôt pas mal ce que tu as fait
ouais ces tarifs qui doit être plutôt
content la fin il se fait pas attendre
humilié que ça au final ça s'est plutôt
pas mal ce qui fait ouais sur le 3 + 2
il a quand même gagné une section de
match ok fin mais tu vois on repart dans
notre truc c'est un truc de cette basse
et hyper chaud ouais y'a un vince et on
repart dans le bon système les trucs 17
c'est le truc 17 a gagné 6-0 le premier
matin et a perdu 7,6 le deuxième mais un
set partout
on s'en fiche doit à ses fins enfin je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez dans le
chat un je ne sais pas non les départage
si égalité à la fin des matchs est
rejoint à 5 plus de 1 3 + 2 et 1 + 1 de
mémoire je te fais trois nouvelles
parties rip les cheveux dessous
plus francs qu'ils montrent qu'ils
connaissent la règle de la règle de sang
d'uriné mais je ne suis pas sûr sont ils
prêts pour ça ont-ils manger avant vous
combien sommes-nous sur le tchat
voilà faisons que la négation qui
s'imposent on va d'autant 350 planches
m'en reste pas mal puisque a pas trop de
suspense et puis à 2 mois de suspense le
monde va regarder des partages jusqu'à
demain matin comme ça rattrape jamais à
la pression avec ça finit par un bull
est enfin de l'ombre devrait revoir club
à londres est il pas content du tout
prix qu'on observe sochan devant sa
caméra
je veux voir fab bon c'est pas ça
transforme à d'autres 350 un truc comme
ça
ouais mais c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
quand même par rapport au fait que ça
passe trop de suspense merci à vous de
suivre le match avec nous et on
je vous promets que mardi ce sera plus
plus serré salut de jukebox et n'oubliez
pas l'air de vous un de vous abonner
aussi à la chaîne switch on s'abonne on
s'abonne de partout soit youtube sur
tweets sur est un lien vers le fils aimé
des liens vers facebook et le twitter de
chasse comme ceux de la connexion ou le
twitter le tweeter le twitter c'est ça
le facebook jamais l'adresse url
totalement
[Musique]
bon ces jeux on s'est fait marcher
dessus par les autres pays j'aimerais
seulement voilà je sais pas en fait
j'arrive pas à justifier d une époque
vous préfériez des abonnements si on
monte vite à l'abri non mais sait on est
on est on est malade tu as loupé je veux
dire sur votre ancien coins de monde sur
les autres trucs va jeu je sais pas quoi
j'essaye de regarder les échecs c'est
quand même un des jeux les plus
regardées en ce moment sur twitter
euh bah c'est numéro 10 numéros
donc ça joue là c'est partie des
bulletins et c'est une sorte de méthode
ruiz direct un petit pion en bessin
qu'on sait pas ce qu'il fait là mais bon
quand on déclare mark mcghee jeu dans
l'esprit magnus moan et au tourisme
c'est quasiment une risquant même bah
oui allez d'antijeu bull d'anti jeu là
surtout de par ok alors c'est qu'on
trouve surtout à l'alcool je suis les
calissons reese est ce que fantastique
quand il se marque est très content de
sa méthode horrible secret des échecs
des gages à les acheter
[Musique]
dommage
bon je vous le voir à 6 pour compléter
les audruicquois ben il aurait peut-être
dû le faire ce qui perd son foot 15 mars
ne faut pas se voiler reconduit ce mardi
vous n'êtes pas l'équipe lotto position
il serait heureux fr torah c'est déjà
tout défendre d'un v6 cela coûtera
talent fou 3 4 non mais du coup en fait
quand il a joué contre moi et je veux
dire je suis tombé contre un génie
g4 enfin une partie enfin une vraie
partie d'échecs
il est très content en fait si froid ils
font jamais de granby en fête du coup vu
qu'ils aiment bien faire des trucs
débiles en fait il devrait réhabiliter
la g mais parce qu'on du cavalier h7 ça
va ça vient
brika et b3 on espère fou prend inscrits
pour passer sinon si on prend un de ses
bateaux à voile à ses parents un
principe d'un poisson mais ok mais non
il en sur damas est la dame qui font des
gaffes et progrès oui qu'il prend des
cartons et des deux ans résident si dans
six danses ils dansent novès est très
heureux des baffes et damas est en fête
bah oui mais ça l'est via ce blog n'est
ma guise en train de se marrer bah ça le
fait trop rigoler il doit se dire tout
ils tous lokua common surtout to which
tous nos patrons non mais ça va le faire
marrer sérieusement non en fait tu vois
si juste les deux parties des bills à
machin et marque deux points de plus il
y aurait 11 14 ans fait ben tu as su le
dire enfin il peut pas être en mode
foutage de gueule comme ça contre gries
tout quand même c'est pas possible
ok mais pourquoi on essayera de ça
contre manu c'est contre nous ils ratent
jamais tu as juste c'était lui et
d'autres aux noms mais ça c'était
quelque chose que je n'existe plus bang
et aura comme dam des spin the way me
croyais froid et la finale du ppt ion
sera gagnant es-tu en usant ok tu peux
faire f 5 mai va apprendre il est en
train de se marier mort de rire mais il
est complètement nul
débat je prendrai la jeanne j'entendais
un bruit et puis rien ouais et on vit
dans le chat et magnus il est à peine à
40% mais c'est ça en fait fin et c'est
trop dessus
ces gens racontent dans votre boulot
même ne se transforme en porc super
guerrier en fait s'en fout et se battre
j'arrive en voie de krynn se battre en
fait rien de défense
oui ça s'arrête déjà sali te défendre
bref
mais comme c'étaient de très contents de
leur campagne où elle n'a pas donné que
vous puis la baie il n'a pas le seul à
rien weight a réuni je crois que ma vie
je vais plus sérieusement la tâche des
gangs en effet nul est très très sérieux
là et si je me suis sérieuse it et 200%
nani s'est même pas besoin de se
transforme en super saiyan
non mais bon enfin j'adore salle à
manger des trois fous quand même faire
gaffe c'est que j'avais gagné une partie
contre vague aniane comme ça en blitz
encore des clous le roi je vous un jour
et le oui à une fronde de ses héros à
agen j'ai vu un grand dam leca râler
mais j'ai ici j'ai le droit
bon tu n'as pas le droit de vote si j'ai
fait ça en fait j'ai tout fait froid et
faim il est vrai que vrai saddam quand
bien même on dégage quoi après la vie
continue et à la joue et qu'il n'était
pas content de moi et quand même jouer
quoi faire un genre comme si si j'avais
fait un truc quoi et tu n'as pas le
droit d'enlever trois ça va pas marcher
il va se rendre fou des six à un moment
donné un vrai pas directement fait
d'avoir tu vas te faire mater la barre
est jugée trop hot pour nous manque et
damashek légère fouache 200 cause des
saints tu dégages elke m6 qui protège h
quatre vingt qui couvrent h4 aller ok on
attend on va faire notre jeu de la
dernière fois il ya neuf points d'écart
et ce qu'il a gagné malgré un temps de
jeu reste 22 minutes du gong résonne de
partout possible c'est une foule
on a regardé sans 4 680 personnes sur
l'estrie en espagnol en fait un gros
buzz - table avant on avait plus que les
espagnols c'est déjà fini
mais bon c'était sûr qu'un jour ou
l'autre façon on pouvait pas tout le
temps à plus de gens que les espagnols
c'est pas possible on est plus gothique
non mais c'est surtout que enfin ils
font beaucoup plus d'efforts à faire bon
déjà est beaucoup moins de monde en
terme de population c'est ridicule les
gens ce rapport aux politiques mais en
fait les jeunes via l'amérique du sud
via lisbonne auquel les états unis aussi
il ya plein de l'espagnol mais oui puis
en plus en france et beaucoup de le dire
en termes de réseaux sociaux toutes
sortes de gens sur internet qui parlent
espagnol en plus c'est encore plus
ridicule que de gens qui parlent juste
espagnole ce coquet temps disons très
connectée internet genre en espagne mon
coeur hélas comme la france mais les
états unis le site a une énorme
population hispanique et les types
mexique et tout ça les corses ont
beaucoup sur internet alors que nous
avec 4 way la part de chou naïve à
pousser les pions des éloignés père de
fou pour prendre cinq tailles très
heureux connexes 3 il se marre là il se
remet à ça je démarrais cheveux qui lui
pense d'une tactique
qu'est ce que le mec ça il est en train
de se marrer total genre je suis très
content d'avoir perdu ce serait foutu de
ma gueule pas possible tellement bien
marché ou à refaire donc dix points
d'écart il reste combien de temps vont
bientôt
un lieu où ces deux nouveaux
l'humiliation mais en fait c'est juste
en 3 + 2 il a baissé la garde mais sinon
il sait où des prix garde contre sa
mémoire c'est un truc de great choc avec
hull excuses s2games la guitare comme
des galets museau guitare mais qu'est ce
que c'est que cette kia byers est un mec
avec une bombe trois ans
regus ambulants les vrais échecs
chiffonnant mais ils ont des sujets
propres à tous étudiés martin me semble
je pense beaucoup plus pédagogiques
terre balles de plastique y as bien
comme étant m alors n'y a même pas du
tout ce qu on s'en fout
j'aime bien voilà je suis plus avisés ok
on peut m'apprendre 3 et à les mater
comme une merde
enfin prend f2 ok on prend et on va
prendre des caf
bayon prend des cats a bloqué mais bon
enfin n'exagère pas je compte 10 ultime
message aux discordes c'était bien les
échecs à 4 on est tous très contents cap
adam g 3g mais on va faire un des vidéos
des chats car c'est trop bien soin pour
pranger de qui va arriver faut pranger 4
maintenant j'ai regardé sa tête va de
nouveau se marrer a lille entre hal et
enfin de se marrer est en train de juby
le kosovo est horrible je conclure live
tu vas te faire chambrer à chaque coupe
tous ces cas pour ta gueule je m'en
fiche déception quoi
mais ok mais d'un autre côté est ce que
c'est pas tout mais jusqu'à 2
de faire ce chambrage total pourquoi ça
pourquoi pas faire mais je dis c'est
violent quoi fâcher pas le mec est plus
fort ok fallait il fait exactement comme
avec laurent quoi il se fout de sa
gueule total c d amy st non mais en fait
ça dépend d'un truc jusqu'au n'est pas
magnus perso du tout s'il se laisse
chambre et sur d'autres trucs où il est
nul dans ces cas là ça va quoi mais je
m'en il a l'air d'être sport quoi je
pense sinon c'est un peu too much
je suis pas sûr que ce très nul un truc
non mais forcément nul à un truc sur
scène on est tous nuit là quelque chose
je sais pas quel âge il est pas sûr
non mais je pense que tu changes au
total ont créé ce rythme on y regarde
partout centre à me taper sur internet
c'est ce que google nuls à quelque chose
est ce que quelqu'un sait il ya quelque
chose d'étrange pas sûr sur discorde
avec le groupe et il dise pas oui ils
perdent 2 et 6 4
je leur réponds
à 4
damien 15 tours à cas dans les étoiles à
jay frye g3 est ok ans maintenant mais
il voulait faire machine à thé voulait
sortir le fou genre quand tu vois les
accords mais quel est l'intérêt rim ne
se risque pas qu'il en soit pas pire aux
gardes tu fais ce que tu fais là
mais un médecin jean floc'h et pour
votre compte trois ou quatre une quatre
stades vote pas que ça se joue mais en
fait le revenu en jeu si ce n'est de
leur or g62 traiteront fois ci c'est
qu'il recruterait pas laisser ça en fait
tu vas être en outre anglais ont foulé 3
tout comme peu importe ce qui va mettre
les pieds à quatre c4
c'est un fou des trois c4 ont choisi la
côte est echl ou de l'autre ouais ouais
c'est ça le fric tard zigzag à cinq
[Musique]
bâtons fourcade fo b 5e cinq combattants
tiens regarde quasi fantastique alors
attends si ce que faire de plus 12 il
reste qatariens sont pas encore
mathématiquement gagner mais s'il gagne
celle là c'est mathématiquement fini
5 je souhaite m'en sers à rien puis
n'existe pas tu n'attaquera jamais tu
vas être obligé de faire petit rock mais
il est mort devait rependre absolument
tout le match en fait non mais c'est
juste dingue mais c'est tellement
humiliant
il ose dire les cieux tard
mathématiquement gagner ou pas encore
demandé
voilà il est quand même plus classe que
grille choqué que lui il a pas fait je
suis parti à fond il a juste dû julliard
coach de l'autre sens bonjour je n'ai
pas besoin de subterfuges pour gagner
dommage qu'ils aient pas d'un match 5 de
prendre on espère d'abord des oeufs 2
quand même sens le front
il va réussir a chopé un truc pour toi
non qu'il veut bloquer contre 7 qui
mangent bon je trouve cette c6 ou des
six ans maintenant
mais bon ok c'est par un pur pas six ans
c'est pas si simple moi c'est perdre
holt non c'est perdable
elle anime zozos qui tweet ou socoa
c'est ça
et m6
mais rien tout débute je refusais il
fait cette caisse est une forteresse est
juste rien
du coup ok je t'annonce officiellement
que si tiens celle là il a
officiellement gagné si je vois votre au
bronze ça passe
alors puisqu'il ya encore une partie de
960 qui comptent pas dans le chrono
c'est incroyable rodez 6
[Musique]
ces sept on va tendre balayé plein je
joue des touches trop tôt at il dit peu
cette super mathématiquement perdre si
j'ai réussi à jouer mais pascal et il
rentre dans le truck mathématiquement en
train de rentrer dans le truck
mathématiques parce qu'en fait ils
arrivent à onze minutes de match reste
douze parties pour encore égaliser
c'est de la gagner
gonul et tu penses que s'il allait mais
même là il a plus de 12,6 et ses pairs
il en perdrait maison mettre encore en
fait si personne là en deux minutes il a
gagné mathématiquement et sert que si
les six heures qui va rentrer dans la
zone u mathématiquement gagnants au
cours de cette partie femme choquée à la
partie valeurs ont duré plus d'une
minute trente
ce que tu as quand même une seconde par
coup voilà notre appel pas partie de
talent avec des 5,5 et j'ai cinq pôles
ou gajewski 5,5 m
il se marre je vais à calais très
content d'y avoir des 5,5 froid à 6,7 kg
au début du cd da il se marre à cause de
ça je vais devoir quelques cadeaux à
tous je te mets le font leurs allées des
simples balades et 5 mai puis on prend
que la même si on prend j'attaque bien
croire que j'en prends ça avec les mêmes
problèmes pour great choc en fait juste
great show qui va arriver beaucoup plus
proches aux bulles est mais j'ai peur
que ça raconte enfin on sera mardi en
fait
maigrichon qui est pas mal on vous
attend beaucoup ouais mais en fait il a
dit qu' il avait été impressionné
il pense qu'il est plus fort et je suis
pas je ne suis pas ici depuis une heure
dégage attention à tes des connecteurs
ça j'ai déconnecté
on ne veut plus voir ce match
intéressant personne n'est pas actif une
avoir dégagé pas vu comment il se fait
défoncer joue encore
mais bon il en train de l'être mais oui
en fait ouais ce qu'ils disent est ce
que cette attention ce qu'ils disaient
c'est qu'il est aussi qu'il est plus
impressionnant que hikaru encore est en
fait il s'agit s'attendait pas à ça du
tout critique meilleur maintenant belote
mais en fait ils pensaient juste qu'ils
étaient très forts genre maxi machin
mais pas genre plus fort que n'a qu'à
pas via internet un genre le fait que
jamais et tout ça enfin comment tu peux
être aussi rapide mais qui a dit que
yopougon qui impressionné par votre
nourriture est impressionné par carole
scène
mais moi je suis né parmi tous
non mais il va vite comment fais tu as
tu devras 205 plus de son propre +2 tu
vois un pépère tranquille quoi et en
fait des qui dans minetti ni speed quoi
ils jouent bien atteint il joue toujours
bien et les farguais tout ce jeu ça me
tue à peine une minute c'est pas un
problème pour lui mais ça donne autant
pions enfin voici
serait ce une crop qui avait frappé 5e
remonte la cave et les f3 dégâts je suis
en paix du fer g5 je fais bessin et je
fais la grotte de l'autre côté la partie
pédagogique des classes
on sera aussi bam h 40 ou faute des
syncopes dame hkd souvent comme un arbre
et à y perdre un match et je vais le
défoncer le plus bref de damages qu'adam
g iii vas-y bout et des champions dames
g3 prochain ailleurs encore le fou qui
pourra défendre une carte
j'ai cinq ans fut jamais à temps il veut
faire maintenant un kayak strokes oui il
veut faire marcher les cavaliers f3 puis
on prend date à annoncer marche quand
messi mouiller et puis on prend
fouquereau f3 et d'hommes j'ai trouvé
mg3 mata prêt et je suis vraiment rester
froide alger deux font preuve de vue
provoque bien ouais ça c'est le pire des
pires wii se marre des otages les free
de la gravette avec moi tu n'existe plus
ce n'est pas dans l'esprit du jeu n'a
jamais été dans l'esprit je suis allée
matifou sont qu'une alarme je ne peux
plus voir se traîne partie je suis assez
la qualité faire recette le vin tout va
s'échanger puis il aura 40 pions de plus
de 5 ans devenu fou b4 tu ne viendra
jamais en c5 dégage
elle se marre pour celui de l'auteur est
temps qu'on se sont entretenus
j'abandonne émeutes mais j'ai quatre
années
hairaz l'absurde l'homme ainsi pourquoi
ça le fait marrer mais je pense qu'ils
préfèrent gilles cateau prochain mais
tel degré de marcheuses foulée 5 h de
marche dessus on joue de iweb kuan yew
notre bonne finale très bien bon
ministre il ferait socoa et ça le fait
super mare et d'échangé le dail super je
comprends que ça cloche retrait 06 nay
du coup on avait raison en ce sens on
disait +9 s'était même léger quoi et
c'est plus cela fut fait en regardant la
télé c'est +14 là j'imagine pas
seulement ils sont arrêtés +20 dégage
futur kasparov était très très doux
énorme ok mais il est fort mais c'est
juste qu'on rigole du fait de tous les
observateurs extérieurs qui te parler
dessous enfin on a l'impression et de la
faire avec des modèles sont trop
promenade en fait si je suis sans leur
patriotisme mais pas du tout objectif
quoi mais là c'est un monstre je n'ai
jamais vu ça il ne jamais sa proie à
chacun alors là ça ressemble plutôt
mélange raté entre nos films orfi et
fisher nom slime maroc et mais le mec
joue bien mais j'ai repéré par rapport
au prix d un père dont jacques a fait
très froid je prends je suis tous rêvent
de hk se marrent j'encaisse un pion
d'également je fais de komodo et vous
conservez psion htv gage ou en voiture
une truie et acheter des gages est en
train de danser dans son cas c'est fou
ça fait 10 06
dès qu'ils encaissent du matos a fait
marrer découvert ird ans de partout et
saint gobain donc voyez tout ça ce sont
les trois branches quatre touches des
huit voies supportant des golfeurs
qu'aujourd'hui que de la compassion mais
alors où va t'on bloqué mais c'est pas
ça c'est à cause de sarkozy doit être
gentil avait carrément apprendra rien
contre lui le boss bon j'ai pas aimé que
l'on s'enflamme comme ça sur le flop
ça ne méritait pas tu n'es pas dans
l'esprit ou non et moi c'est pas ça
c'est plus que magnus il fait tellement
marrer quand il rigole comme ça que tu
veux voir les plus âgés 5
h saint barth ou non eric mso dommage
que la faf
voilà tour géminides n'avais juste ce
marché dit il aurait dû être plus
agressif en début de match serait pas
fait autant marcher dessus je pense
des six votre perdre comme comme le rapt
la ja les commodos surtout toujours un
nouveau bal cours d'eau sont là donc je
remonte à moi même temps d'éduquer b52 s
3 dans les trois cas il est bon en fait
on va prendre d'ici ce que ça donne mais
8 on prend à ses 7 qui la perpet bravo
mon père ayant de leur vie enfermé dans
ma vie il y aura parfaitement
ah non il n'ya pas permettre ainsi la
ilaha illa balle la balle et 1.637 ou
mixtes où je pense qu'ils gagnent ou non
la gueule par la thanatologie 6,6 il
commence à rigoler s'amuser mais c'est
pas elle a peut-être encore peur du tour
des trois tours à 3 machin je sais pas
si on prend des quatre classes
[Musique]
madame cécile bergerie comme scarabée
cet ehpad te caches turcs ont voté riez
telus pro trouve moi c'est ça la
desserte habilité à la rentée vite
bon donc tu fais pions des 6 es tu te
bats retour à 8 le ressenti des
sentiments mais c'est un carnage à 2 à 0
ce qu'il a fait ne serait-ce qu'une wii
il a fini la preuve non à l'europe c'est
la dernière fois je pense que je te
surprend pas si je te dis que
mathématiquement bonbonnes ministre est
même dans son chambrage reste aux
classiques ati tu n'es pas de chance
d'avoir un jeu 4 h 5 2 bat en finale
même si tu fais des voitures débit il ya
quand même
il va quand même quand ils te battre
fait un truc classique quelque part le
plaçons de pièces et où il ya de la
propreté dans son jeu lachance pâquis et
de grappins 959 se comptent pas comme
une grappe
enfin plus est c'est un gros handicap
non mais là il est pas super bien ces
structures car tu vas ne leur a pas été
super super bien cela il aura pas mal
maîtrisé c'est un peu seul truc qu'il a
maîtrisée en fait
comme le souhaitait était pas mal en
trois plus de seulement d'un camion
algorithmes le prédisait qu'après 10 à
gauche pour les points 0 je passe est un
massacre est prêt il précise à cet
ennemi 3 lisais un truc comme 25
plusieurs grosses différences sont là
leur prédisait 4,8 pour cent de chance
pour cent de gagner deux matches
l'algorithme avant dévissé lourdement
planté caen fin juin que c'était plus
proche du zéro en fait il ya une faute
dans la virgule en fait cédé 0,48 là
encore il faut dire que tu n'es pas la
seule dans l'histoire
de fait mal pour les uns marais
mais tous quittant le nom de partie par
la commune une pièce de plus c'est
espère résister à tous les quatre des
cinq tous des changes
je suis pas sortie a bien fait pas au
pire tu as assumé
têtu de fer d'amd de il peut essayer de
tuer adam f1 qui avait fait un mort un
peu le chouchou des 3 5 3 je reviens le
revenant et après dame g2a will be back
puis on prend d'un match 3 des cages
dommage j'aime bien
[Musique]
dommage qu'il valait le maté en fait je
pense ça s'apprend des cinq sections de
partout qui saute
ouais mais à une manade de côté aussi
bakou g6 crise prises et folle en plus
hauts fourneaux way est en fait le
cavalier pas le dominer à un moment
donné ok mais tu pousses
niveau ambiance festive avons même qu'on
voit la gagne on va te mettre en patois
française une plongée fonds va faire un
truc comme ça on va trouver une victoire
on peut mettre le fond en d5 est en
train de danser c'est ça tu es fou monde
et ça le fait marrer
[Rires]
non la dernière game pour le monde
puisse 17 était numéro 6 mondial battu
fait moins bien que blues une offre
pourtant hélas la fin magnus surtout
dire oui je suis très mécontent de mon
style de mon niveau de jeu mais là je
pense qu'il est content et quand mr très
heureux pas plus que quand vous c'est
une affaire sert de le faire vraiment
marrer mais peut-être que le rêve a bien
lui d'autres sceptiques répondants sont
quant à eux toujours 0 0 le real non je
pense qui m'intéressait c'était le but
de lukaku mais a dû marquer plein de
points politiques il est le capitaine
c'est x 3 il partit 20 points pour son
équipe je sais pas ça se tape mais enfin
je pense que psychologiquement même j'ai
pas tu penses à peut avoir un impact
pour les parties en real après benjamin
nonin quoi ça tu t'es quand même fait
démolir
qu'est ce que c'est que ça les pros de
peu d'armes ok il s'est fait des bruits
dans ça le fait marrer et cloisons
perdant septième art est quand même
étrange et l'arnaqué sais même pas si
simple pour les blancs non ok mais
justin est mille fois plus fort
non mais c'est dingue mais et foucault
et jack classique c'est le lys le niveau
alors qu'on pourrait faire un truc pour
que le meilleur gagne pas pour ils vont
te dit je vais te raconter le contraire
la france se reprend anesthésiant c'est
quoi le score à chaque sommet de huit
points quoi ce vote il parle guy novès a
sauté en cas de défaut balazs lens est
bien parti pour six ont défoncé nos
parents on y dit que goffin bas il a
gagné en fait quand dimitra goff a
annoncé que ça car les syndicats n'ont
rien set partout je suis en train de
savourez ce pont du bateau de la
compagnie libyenne clé qui ne pointe
qu'à une pièce de plus la tête était de
moins malin mais je suis passé de
l'attenté et pas de grosses découvertes
en fait on souffle et h4 peut-être dams
et 5,2 me prendre truc de me décider je
pense vu avec lui imputant mt [ __ ]
c'est un grand et la b5 et chaque e kg 3
ont été fixées par un objet sur les
dames ton oui mais pendant japonais mais
la faute d'être gagnante venez français
repasse option va surtout pions en
campus
oui il va se faire défoncer bon ben
voilà onze ans mais combien il a gagné
le la cession de la tour on aura le
vicomte ce sont surtout vrai sur 13
points comme ceux qui ont aidé à 18,8
ba2 la loi je vais te [ __ ] optimiste
+18 quoi 3 quel démolition la machine
coup droit revers vraiment
impressionnant femmes mais elles se sont
arrêtées sont le vainqueur de la télé
lui 36 dans l'impressionnant hockey aux
cages en verre histoire d'apprécier
comme bacchus toujours très beau nom
mais d'un côté tu vois ce que je veux
dire c'est que d'un côté on dit ok y'a
pas de suspense et tout mais on a quand
même assisté à un récital ce comme moi
tu vois un match que federer 6 3 6 2 6 0
mais ok ses récitals voilà tant
d'erreurs longue ligne de revers croisé
des cheats des volets qu'ils haïssent je
sais plus quoi tend peu plus des breaks
tas de tout bon et mardi et mardi au
quai quand on va voir ce que ça donne
face à face à l'ombre de match ok tu me
vient des que c'est confirmé c'est vous
dire à 99% là c'est sûr c'est en fait et
c'est il fallait que ce soit magnus qui
gagne pour que de la sueur oui ok fait
juste office you
ouais il aura posé 10 1/2 en bullet
froid qui joue pas mal le bien non il
est pas mauvais bon bah écoutez les mecs
ok je remets un lien aussi à notre
chaîne youtube le lien direct en
espérant qu'ils marchent n'êtes pas
encore abonné chaîne youtube abonnez
vous ouais ben rejoindre quoi la ville
et sur bitume coin là je n'ai pas de
compte ou pour en créer un site très
très rapide la chaîne twitch ici aussi
il faut s'abonner donc vous sa bonne de
partout eh ben on se retrouve mardi à
aller à mardyck oua oua ventre les
vidéos notamment sur les vidéos mais si
même 19 heures l'ombre de vlad a les
attentions
ciao ciao les gars